Ja, hi Kilian.
Hey Hendrik.
Machst du Sonnencreme dabei?
Das wäre echt angebracht.
Wir sitzen hier gerade am Teich der Fakultät Informatik in der Sonne.
Es ist sehr angenehm.
Ich dachte eigentlich, Sommer wäre schon vorbei.
Nee, irgendwie kommt er gerade noch mal so ein bisschen zurück.
Aber ich finde es ja nicht ganz cool.
Ich wünschte bloß gerade, ich hätte eine kurze Hose dabei.
Ich glaube, bei der Uhr sind es 18 Grad.
Also wenn sich irgendwann die Akustik ändert und wieder so einen leichten Hall hört, dann war es uns zu viel.
Dann ist entweder uns zu warm geworden oder der Wind zu laut oder die Sonne zu dolle oder das WLAN ist raus oder die Akkus unserer Laptops waren alle.
Und dann haben wir uns wieder ins ASCII reingesetzt.
Dabei ist ja gerade das Schöne an der Teiche draußen, dass man eigentlich WLAN hat.
Also man sitzt hier quasi in der freien Natur und hier ist WiFi mehr oder weniger und auf der Wiese sind Steckdosen.
Ja, ein bisschen weg weg.
So lange ist mein Kabel nicht.
Ich glaube, da ist das Wifi ein bisschen mies.
Wir könnten vielleicht hier so ein,
wir haben so ein Ausrollkabel, aber ich weiß nicht, wie lange das reicht.
Aber da müsste ich sagen, hätte ich am liebsten
mittlerweile, wenn wir es hier echt durchziehen wollen,
noch so einen Sonnenschirm und vielleicht so einen Tisch.
Diesmal werde ich es nicht vergessen.
Schaut mal jetzt ins Coverart vom Podcast,
dann seht ihr ein Bild vom Teich, wo wir gerade sitzen,
falls ihr es nicht kennt.
Super düdlisch. Also wenn ihr noch nicht studiert,
wenn ihr noch Schüler seid oder sowas,
Dann kommt auf jeden Fall zum Informatikstudieren nach Dresden.
Wir haben die schönste Fakultät.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Das ist echt ein wunderschönes Gebäude.
Wunderschöner Teich.
Ja, ansonsten, was gibt es bei dir so Neues?
In letzter Zeit nicht sehr viel.
Die Semesterferien sind bei mir irgendwie recht ruhig geblieben.
Ich habe, also meine Freundin und ich haben uns zwei Katzen zugelegt,
dass es uns was passiert ist.
Zwei, das letzte Mal, als wir geredet haben, war es noch eine.
Ja, wir wollten zwei, weil eine Katze ist irgendwie ein bisschen doof,
die gerade vor allem, wenn sie so jung sind,
zwei, ich glaube jetzt drei Monate
alte Katzen. Max und Moritz heißen sie.
Echt jetzt? Ja.
Wer war der Erste? Moritz.
Deswegen musste die zwei. Unbedingt.
Das wäre ja blöd gewesen.
Die sind super süß. Ich würde überall an den Händen sacken.
Ja, ich sehe es. Du machst so ein bisschen
einen Emo-Eindruck.
Das ist eine ganz schön große Narbe,
stehe ich gerade fest. Ja, aber die ist nicht tief.
Die geht direkt über die Ader.
Und die sind beide gleich alt?
Ja.
Ja, cool.
Das ist süß. Ansonsten mache ich nicht viel.
Ich habe bloß am Campus-Navigator
weitergebaut, diese App für die TU Dresden,
wo ich der aktuelle iOS-Maintainer
bin. Ist das mittlerweile dein
Swift-Rewrite oder ist das immer noch das Legacy-Zoll?
Ich mache am Swift-Rewrite jetzt wieder mehr weiter.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf die Legacy.
Und ist das deployed schon? Benutzt du es jetzt schon?
Nein. Das heißt, das ist immer noch so ein U-Boot-Projekt von dir?
Ja, das wird auch noch eine kleine Weile bleiben.
Aber ich würde mich schämen.
Das Blöde ist ja, dass
der Legacy-Code,
der Legacy-Ding, an dem ich arbeite,
der ist halt auch ein V-Ride, aber
da sind ein paar Sachen, finde ich, ein bisschen umständlich
gelöst und sehr ausführlich
und das ist so ein bisschen sehr so
diverse Patterns umgesetzt, was ich
halt unnötig finde für diese Code-Basis
und sehr viel
in Objective-C und ich dachte mir, ich kann das gerade
für mich auch mal ganz gut nutzen, das Projekt,
um da ein bisschen was dran zu lernen und zu machen
und für den nächsten halt in Swift
bereitzustellen. Deshalb habe ich da ein paar Sachen
recht ekelhaft reingehackt und jetzt würde ich
mich sehr schämen, wenn ich das Projekt irgendwann abgebe,
das in seiner aktuellen Form so abzugeben.
Du willst es erstmal aufräumen, ja?
Ich will den Rewrite fertig kriegen.
Ich meine, ich habe aus der bestehenden Call-Ball super viel gelernt.
So ist es nicht.
Und falls derjenige, der die geschrieben hat, hier zuhören würde,
weil sie super cool fänden würde,
dann bin ich auch echt stolz,
das Projekt weitergemacht zu haben in der Form.
Aber ich will es trotzdem auch mal geschrieben.
Außerdem würde sich gerade dieses Projekt super gut eignen,
um bei Apple für ein WWDC-Scholarship sich zu bewerben,
wenn die sowas wieder annehmen.
Ja, das hast du ja schon mal gekriegt, ne?
Ja, letztes Jahr.
Wofür war das da?
Da habe ich mich mit Parken-DD beworben,
mit dieser Open Data Parken-App.
Aber da habe ich denen halt viel zu Open Data vorgeschwärmt gehabt.
Und die App ist meines Erachtens immer noch recht lächerlich,
dafür, dass sie mir ein Scholarship gegeben haben.
Es ist halt weniger Open Data, als du hast einen Scraper gebaut, ne?
Ne, das ist halt der Teil im Wecken.
Das hat mit der App nichts mehr zu tun.
Die App ist halt einfach nur minimalistisch und
vielleicht minimalistisch noch ganz
okay aussehen. Aber was hat Packen die mit Open Data
zu tun? Ja, wir
kratzen halt, okay, doch, das ist schon der Scraping
anders. Wir holen die Daten halt daher, wo sie halt nicht
frei sind und versuchen so viele
heterogene Quellen wie möglich zu
vereinen und da möglichst
sehr maschinenlesbar
nach außen freizugeben und wir
sammeln die Daten auch, was die anderen
Quellen halt nicht machen, damit wir halt auch so Dinge wie
diese Prognosen rausrechnen können und
da hat noch ein bisschen mehr Wert drüber. Also
Beschreibung. Das ist
nice. Genau das. Gibt es ja nicht irgendwann
so ein bisschen rechtliche Probleme?
Ich dachte eigentlich, die wären schon längst gekommen, aber bisher nicht.
Achso, naja. Jetzt, wo das
alle in unserem Podcast hören werden.
Aber recht cool war ja am Anfang, wir hatten das ja für
Dresden erstmal umgesetzt, weil jetzt aber heißt die App auch so
blöd, wir wollen die aktuell unbedingt. Falls ihr irgendeinen
Namensvorschlag für die App habt, gerne her damit.
Wir haben noch nichts Gutes gefunden.
Wir hatten das für Dresden
umgesetzt und die App...
Parkhouse Watch.
Mein Vorschlag war ja Open Park, aber
Das klingt so ein bisschen nach was, wo du spazieren gehen kannst.
Wir hatten das für Dresden umgesetzt und dann war es in der SZ in der Sächsischen Zeitung.
Und wirklich wenige Tage später hat uns die Stadtverwaltung Zürich angeschrieben gehabt
und gesagt, dass sie das in der SZ gelesen haben.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die Stadtverwaltung Zürich die Sächsische Zeitung ist.
Vielleicht haben sie die Süddeutsche gesucht und die falsche gefunden.
Ja, das ist immer so.
Und haben gesagt, dass sie ihre Daten ja schon längst Maschinenlieferien
veröffentlichten im Open Data Portal.
Ob wir nicht auch eine App für die schreiben wollen,
haben wir gesagt, nee, warte mal, wir packen die einfach in unsere App rein.
Und seitdem, ein paar Wochen später,
konnte die App dann schon die erste, zweite
starten, seitdem noch viel mehr.
Und die fanden das super cool, haben das auch auf ihrer Webseite
ein paar Mal veröffentlicht und das finde ich immer noch das Coolste,
dass die Stadt direkt auf uns zugekommen ist
und das toll fand.
Muss ich mal drauf achten, meinst du, die Zürich wirbt
einen auch schon für Parken.de?
Zumindest auf der Webseite ist es mal erwähnt, aber ich glaube,
die werben nicht aktiv für die App oder so.
Die ist kostenlos werbefrei, da ist ja nichts dabei.
woran wir das, da ist auch nichts
an Tracking-Kram mit drin
beziehungsweise war es tatsächlich mal, bevor ich
gemerkt habe, dass die Plattform, die ich dafür nutzte
ja gekauft wurde von Google und dann
wollte ich das draus haben
Ich fahre ja demnächst nach Zürich
Stimmt, was ist da los?
Da ist das Rustfest
Da fahre ich diesmal alleine hin
Leider keinen weiteren Grund
Du kennst auch schon genug Leute aus Community, oder?
Ja, genau, ich freue mich ja schon drauf, es ist für mich hauptsächlich so ein bisschen
Klassentreffen-Charakter, mal ein paar Leute wieder treffen
Klassentreffen ist geil.
Ich habe auch
konkrete Fragen an so ein paar Leute.
Ich bastle ja gerade, ich habe ein paar
Crates gemacht und eins davon heißt iCalendar.
Da habe ich mich einfach mal getraut, so einen großen Namen zu belegen.
Das kann aber nur Kalenderdaten
schreiben. Dann habe ich schon ein paar Leute
gefragt, hast du nicht auch einen Parser?
Dann habe ich angefangen einen Parser zu bauen mit NOM.
Das ist aber so fürchterlich.
NOM war so ein Parser-Combinator?
Ja, genau.
So richtig Spaß macht es nicht.
Da ist aber hoffentlich der Entwickler
Mit dem bin ich auch auf Twitter relativ häufig in Kontakt, aber der ist auch an der Entwickler dort.
Dann werde ich mit dem mal ein bisschen direkter quatschen.
Ich habe schon E-Mails von Leuten bekommen von diesem einen Typen.
Den kenne ich auch vom Kongress.
Der baut irgendeine krasse Personal Data Management Geschichte,
die jetzt auch schon, der hat selber von sich behauptet, schon vor einem Jahr, als ich das letzte Mal getroffen habe,
dass es 10.000 Zeilen Code sind.
Und der möchte wahrscheinlich das mitverführen.
Da hat er gesagt, oh, ist das nicht auch ein Kalender?
Pariser?
Aber es ist schon echt nice to have.
Gerade iCal ist ein doch recht verbreitetes Format geworden.
Ja, ich bereue eigentlich, dass ich die einfach
in einer naiveren Pariser geschrieben habe.
Aber jetzt habe ich das einmal angefangen.
Naja.
Ich habe ein ähnliches Projekt in Swift tatsächlich,
wo ich mir dann mal die API für die Bilder
von dir geklaut hatte.
Und ich habe letztens,
also ich habe das nie fertig gemacht,
das sollte eigentlich primär der Pariser sein,
weil ich das damals zufällig gerade brauchte.
aber dann habe ich das Projekt
doch erstmal wieder gesunsettet und jetzt habe ich
letztens einen PR bekommen von dem Typen, der will das für irgendein
Projekt nutzen und will das jetzt mal
fertig machen, fand ich super cool, dass
sich einer ranzetzt und da rumbastelt
Ja, der hat sich übelst Mühe gegeben bei dem
Pull-Request und du
hast das aber eigentlich schon längst
gesunsettet oder was? Nee, ich habe es dann auch gemerged
nur nach, du hast mit dir einen Wunsch
dass er diese ganzen Kommentare, das war der, wo ich das mal
gerantet habe, die am Ende von
jeder Klasse, jedem Struck, jeder Extensions und
Kommentarverlegt, hier hört dieses Element wieder auf.
Ja, das ist ein komischer Coding-Style.
Ich glaube, das machen gerade,
ich will den Typ jetzt nicht einschätzen, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wer das ist, aber ich habe das Gefühl, das machen gerade ein paar unerfahrene
Leute manchmal gerne,
damit sie besser strukturieren
und verstehen können,
die Struktur dahinter. Ich fahre auch, wenn ich Code
lese, erstmal anderen rumzuformatieren,
damit es mir leichter fällt, das zu lesen, gerade wenn du
so
ein C++-Code
oder sowas, so
artifizielle Formatierungen hast,
die absolut nichts bedeutet,
einfach bloß irgendwo innerhalb von einem Funktions,
also von so einem Parameterblock,
von einem Funktionskopf,
irgendwo mittendrin einen Umbruch,
das finde ich immer ganz fürchterlich.
Also wenn du innerhalb der runden Klammern
von deinem Funktionskopf umbrichst,
dann hast du irgendwie was falsch gemacht.
Das kommt drauf an.
Also gerade in der Apple-Welt ist es halt relativ populär,
weil du da halt teilweise, keine Ahnung, 200 Zeichen
lange Funktionsköpfe hast. Da wird das
sehr langer. Da machst du dann wieder ein Parameter pro...
Genau, du brichst bei den Parametern um und die werden auch sauber
allein. Was ich aber halt an manchen Stellen sehe,
also was ich bei Python häufig gesehen habe,
da ist halt,
der nimmt halt auch 15
Parameter an, was irgendwie ein Anti-Pattern
ist, finde ich. Das ist schrecklich.
Und dann
ist das halt eine lange Zeile und das
letzte schreibt er auf die nächste Zeile. Das geht
gar nicht. Also wenn, dann konsistent.
Ja, also das war konsistent. Das war immer
hart versucht auf eine Zeile zu kriegen,
dass es nicht mehr ging.
Das ist einfach halt scheiße.
Also zumindest formatiere ich dann immer so ein Code ein bisschen rum,
dass ich es besser lesen kann irgendwie.
Ich finde das Schöne, wenn ein Statement auf einer Zeile ist,
selbst wenn die dann 120 Zeichen lang ist.
Das ist absolut korrekt.
Code-Formatierung macht richtig viel aus.
Ich habe das eine Zeit lang vergessen gehabt,
weil ich der Meinung war,
ich habe meinen Code natürlich immer so formatiert,
wie ich es am schönsten fand.
Ich fühle mich auf ganz normale Dinge,
die ganz normal sind,
dass du da Newlines setzt und Dinge indentest,
sauber und nicht irgendwo random Spaces
einfach zwischen Klammern. Dinge, die sich richtig normal anfühlen.
Und dann habe ich wieder die Veranstaltung gehalten,
dieses Informatik hier für Maschinenbau in der TU,
diese Übung.
Und sobald die halt das Programmieren anfangen,
das ist nicht verallgemeinert,
das ist schwierig, aber sobald manche Leute da das Programmieren anfangen
und dann halt völlig auf jegliche
Form von Inventation und Strukturierung
komplett scheißen. Und dann geht plötzlich
gar nichts mehr. Weil sie halt nicht wissen, wie
Quelltext aussehen muss. Ja, und dann stirbt halt der
Compiler da in allem und du verstehst nicht mehr, wo
und es ist einfach nur noch alles in Visual Studio,
was die Nutzen rot unterkringelt.
Warte mal, versuch mir erstmal Dinge zu balancieren.
Da hast du drei Klammern gelöscht,
die schließen geschwungen alle.
Die müssen halt irgendwo sein.
Und plötzlich, alles durchdummt wieder auch.
Das wäre super simpel gewesen.
Hättest du ein bisschen Formatierung hier geachtet,
dann siehst du, wo die Probleme sind.
Aber nicht, wenn du gefühlt deine gesamte 300 Zeilen
in eine Zeile packst und es dann wundernst,
warum du nichts mehr verstehst.
Da könnte man vielleicht die ersten zwei Minuten
in so einem Programmierkurs mal drüber reden.
Deswegen finde ich es auch,
wenn Leute advokieren,
Code-Highlighting ist was für Kinder.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Ich brauche kein Code-Highlighting.
Das darf alles schwarzer Text auf weißem Hintergrund sein.
Oder so weiter und so fort.
Das nimmt dir aber schon so viel
von deiner Arbeit ab.
Wenn du irgendwo eine Klammer vergisst,
dann siehst du ja, dass das Code-Highlighting
kaputt ist.
War das Rob Pike?
Einer der Code-Wickler?
Ja.
Den brauchen wir, glaube ich, nicht nochmal eingehen.
Naja. Aber apropos Sachen gehen kaputt durch Tickt.
Wir haben ja noch einen Nachtrag zu unserem letzten Podcast.
Da hatten wir auf Twitter geschrieben, so ist es jetzt raus oder ist es gleich raus?
Und dann hat es irgendwie noch einen Tag gedauert oder sowas?
Ja, das Problem ist halt, dass der Feed von unserem Podcast,
die meisten Leute nutzen aus Apple Podcasts den Feed.
Und Apple liest unseren Feed halt auch nur von Soundcloud.
Und Apple hat dafür einen eigenen XML-Parser anscheinend.
Und der ist halt, wie ich dann erst Ewigkeiten später gemerkt habe,
weil da kriegt man ja auch keinen Hinweis dazu,
da muss man sich in dieses Portal einloggen.
Und wenn man vermutet, dass es an der Stelle eben hapert,
ich meine, du weißt ja nicht, an welcher Stelle es kaputt gegangen ist,
dann lockt man sich da ein und da steht plötzlich so eine rote Fehlermeldung,
dass er in irgendeinem illegalen Zeichen da gestorben ist und das nicht parsen konnte.
Und dann ist sich herausgestellt, dass es eben halt in die Shownotes ein Emoji gepackt hatte.
Oh Gott, wie konnte ich nur...
Was traust du dich?
Wir hatten ja schon mal ein Emoji in den Shownotes.
Ja, aber warum hat das dann...
Wir haben schon mal diese Sterne-Emojis, habe ich anfangs immer
benutzt für die... Ne, das war die Chapter Marks.
Ich dachte, wir hatten in den Shownotes schon mal was drin.
Aber das werde ich jetzt auf jeden Fall nie wieder tun.
Gerade bei Apple
gehen keine Emojis im Text.
Apropos, ganz kurz an das Thema
mit angedacht. Ich hatte gestern
einen Bug im Swift-Compiler.
Und zwar
hat der auf... Interessanterweise
ist für den relevant,
wie die Subdirectories in meinem Projekt benannt sind,
weil das nicht klappt.
Ich habe einfach random Compiler-Fehler bekommen
und wurde dann von einem anderen darauf hingewiesen,
dass ich doch mal probieren sollte,
das eine Subdirectorie so umzubenennen,
dass die in einer anderen alphabetischen Reihenfolge sind
und plötzlich ging es.
Die Datei?
Die Ordner.
Ich hatte eine Subdirectorie,
die hieß Models,
da waren Model-Objects drin
und eine hieß Extensions,
wo ich ein paar Extensions reingepackt hatte
Und ich hatte Models,
das ist alphabetisch nach Extensions,
bei M kommt nach E. Und sobald ich Models
auf A-Models umbenannt hatte, ging plötzlich alles.
Und das war schrecklich.
Ach so, weil der das eine liest und das andere dann noch nicht
hat, oder was? Genau, und ich dachte eigentlich,
beziehungsweise sowas sollte keine Rolle spielen.
Und das ist 100 pro ein Bug im Compiler.
Und hab dann mal kurz
in einem Slack für den Swift Package Manager,
ich wollte nicht auf die Mailings hier gehen, aber diesen Slack gibt es halt auch,
und hab da mal kurz gefragt und hat ein Apple-Mitarbeiter
mir gesagt, ja, das ist nicht normal so,
machen wir bitte ein Issue auf. Und Swift hat ja ein
Jira auf bugs.swift.org,
das nur für die Swift-Issues da ist.
Sonst hat Apple ja einen eigenen internen Bug-Tracker,
wo du halt nichts einsehen kannst, sondern nur Dinge öffnen kannst.
Und das Jira ist halt
ein bisschen offener an der Stelle.
Ich habe halt versucht, damit ein Issue
zu feilen in den Jira und bin da plötzlich
nur in Fehlermeldungen reingerannt und schreibe ich dem Typ
nochmal, du, ich kann kein Issue aufmachen. Das klappt nicht.
Und er so, was passiert denn?
Ja, kommt diese Fehlermeldung.
Ja, aber dann hast du irgendein Feld vergessen. Ist irgendwas
rot markiert? Nee, da ist nichts in der Form rot markiert.
Hier ist ein Screenshot davon.
hm, schick mir mal den Text, dann probiere ich es.
Hab ich ihm den Text geschickt, hat er gesagt, ich kann auch
keinen Jira aufmachen.
Ah, warte, das liegt an dem Emoji,
dass du den Text mit reingepackt hast.
Oh, krass.
So, dann wollte er auch und so, wo eröffne ich jetzt
ein Issue für Jira?
Dann hat er gleich auf Bugstart.org noch ein Issue aufgemacht
für Jira und ich wollte, spaßensalber,
unter dieses Issue dann kommentieren mit dem Emoji
und dann ist das fucking Jira hat mir schon wieder
Fehlermeldung hingeworfen.
Hat sie wenigstens, bringt sie Fehlermeldung, bevor es das speichert?
Naja, ja, also es kann halt nicht
Es kommt nicht nur irgendein Zimmer.
Oder wenn du das speichern und dann jedes Mal, wenn du es öffnest,
das irgendwie knallen.
Doch, schrecklich.
Aber ich habe jetzt gerade, eigentlich wollte ich gerade noch ein bisschen was
über Feeds erzählen, aber da können wir gleich noch
darauf zurückkommen, müssen wir uns merken.
Ich hatte jetzt am Freitag
ein Treffen mit
unserem gemeinsamen
Bekannten Henrik von Mozilla.
Der ist ja immer bei dem Rust-Treffen
und hat irgendwie das letzte Mal
einen Vortrag über sein Projekt Gecko-Driver
oder Web-Driver geredet, mit dem sie
Firefox fernsteuern, um damit
irgendwelche Tests zu fahren.
Und ich hatte an dem gleichen Abend
ja noch einen Vortrag über Serde gehalten, eine kleine Demo
und er hat gemeint, oh ja, das wäre eigentlich schön, wenn wir das
da drin verwenden könnten. Und da haben wir uns irgendwie gestern,
äh, vorgestern
getroffen und darüber ein bisschen
gequatscht.
Und als dann irgendwie sich
rauszeichnete, abzeichnete, dass er lieber hätte, dass ich das
baue, als dass er das irgendwie
noch machen muss, weil er noch andere Sachen macht.
Ich meine, Koda auch sonst anderes
Zeugs in meiner Freizeit.
hat er dann gesagt, naja, pass auf, ich zeige dir fix, wie du das machst.
Das Geile ist, Mozilla hat ein großes Monorepository,
das heißt Mozilla Central.
Hat er gesagt, klone dir das mal, bevor wir uns treffen.
Wir haben uns dann hier in der Kneipe getroffen, wo wir beide bloß mobiles Internet hatten.
Es war gut, dass ich mir das vorher geklont habe, das waren irgendwie 8 GB Pupacode.
Und dann
hatte ich das geklont, da war in irgendeinem Unterordner, das war schön sortiert,
war dann der Rust-Code drin.
Und auf dem habe ich dann gearbeitet und habe gemeint, wie arbeite ich denn jetzt darauf, wie checke ich denn das ein?
Ja, pass auf, du gehst erstmal hier auf Bugsilla, dann klickst du da, dann klickst du dort, dann gehst du irgendwie in die Testing-Kategorie unter WebDriver, dann machst du da ein neues Ticket auf und mit diesem Ticket, mit dieser Ticket-Number kannst du dann irgendwie das hochpushen.
Das ist ein komplett anderer Workflow, als du das irgendwie bei Git kennst.
Das hat mich so ein bisschen rausgebracht.
Zumindest musste ich erstmal, also ich habe ihm dann gesagt, pass auf, ich code das.
Und sobald ich was habe, was ich irgendwie einchecken würde, dann kann ich nochmal drüber reden.
Weil ich habe jetzt keinen Bock, das war halt Freitagabend über einem Bier, beziehungsweise über zwei Bier.
Und da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr, mir das zu merken.
Und dann fängst du mit Mutzela an?
Der sagt ja immer, ja, das kannst du immer machen, da hast du schon mal einen Stein im Brett.
Kannst ein bisschen Reputationen bei uns aufbauen, falls du dann irgendwann nicht mal bewirbst.
Wollte ja irgendwie als 15-Jähriger
schon bei Mozilla arbeiten
und er arbeitet auch schon seit
seitdem er 15 ist
oder so an irgendwelchen Mozilla-Projekten.
Ach so?
Aber er ist noch nicht so lange bei Mozilla selbst, oder?
Weiß ich gar nicht so genau.
Ich dachte, beim ersten Meetup hat er gesagt, er ist ja irgendwie
ganz frisch da.
Das habe ich mir nicht genau gemerkt.
Aber
ist das eigentlich alles Open Source
bei Mozilla Central?
Naja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich meine, ich habe mir das alles ohne weiter...
Der hat mir einen Link geschickt und ich habe mir das mal eben runtergeklont.
Da ist auch eigentlich alles drin.
Da steht nicht irgendwo...
Da ist halt wahrscheinlich der gesamte Firefox-Code drin und sowas.
Da steht jetzt nicht explizit Firefox dran.
Da gab es einen Ordner, der heißt Browser.
Das sah ein bisschen so aus.
Schön generisch, falls ich mal umbranden.
Aber ich muss sagen,
also da ist auch sehr viel...
Die haben ja auch so ganz viel
Core-Code in C++ und oben drüber
dann auch sehr viel so Logik-Code
in JavaScript geschrieben.
das habe ich mir mal kurz ein bisschen angeguckt,
aber ich muss sagen, ich kann mir,
ich kann JavaScript nicht mehr vertrauen.
Ich kann mir das nicht angucken und mir denken,
das ist gut, was hier geschrieben ist.
Man hat immer diese Ungewissheit,
da könnte alles passieren.
Ja, da könnte ja alles passieren.
Also ich meine nichts gegen JavaScript,
aber ich möchte, man sollte es glaube ich nicht
so direkt schreiben.
Ich arbeite auf Arbeit
die ganze Zeit mit TypeScript
und wenn du das einmal machst,
das ist schon irgendwie ein schöneres Gefühl.
Ich habe jetzt eine alte Codebase von mir,
weil du auch von deinem
Campus-Navigator erzählst. Also ich habe jetzt auch
eine alte Codebase von mir mal wieder rausgekramt, um mal
ein bisschen rumzuspielen.
Dieses Webspiel in Aubino, an dem ich
gepasst hatte, da dachte ich, da kann ich mal wieder ein bisschen
dran arbeiten. Gilbert hat ja da dann viel mitgemacht.
Und der fängt jetzt auch wieder an,
da irgendwie testdriven Sachen dran zu machen.
Der baut das aber, glaube ich, komplett neu.
Und meine Prämisse war, nee, die Codebase ist einmal
da, ich möchte das irgendwie weiterverwenden.
Ist aber komplett in CoffeeScript geschrieben.
CoffeeScript ist schön. Wir hatten da schon mal
drüber gesprochen, ja. Auch auf dem Podcast?
Ja, aber es ist, ne, wir können es doch gerne
nochmal kurz leicht aufrollen. Also CoffeeScript ist schön,
solange das nur schreiben und nicht mehr lesen muss.
Ich meine, es ist ja mittlerweile
quasi tot, oder? Ich habe auch glaube ich nicht
unbedingt schön gut geschrieben.
Nee, es gibt, es wird jetzt wieder aktiv
an der nächsten Version gearbeitet. Es gibt
CoffeeScript 2. Das unterstützt
dann Async Await.
Das unterstützt das neue
Modulsystem von JavaScript mit.
Und du meinst, da kommt ein schönes JavaScript raus bei dem neuen CoffeeScript.
Jaja, das produziert auch ein moderneres
JavaScript. Das ist cool.
Es hat ein paar Features von JavaScript übernommen
und deprocated auch so ein bisschen was.
Nicht viel.
Und
interessanterweise unterstützt es dann auch
sowas wie Flow.
Flow ist, ich schreibe mal
Type-Annotationen in Kommentaren ran
und lasse dann jemand anderes nochmal drüber gehen.
Irgendwie ein Linter dann, der schaut.
Irgendwie, den ist ein Linter, genau.
Und der macht quasi
Typsystem als, ich schreibe es ran.
Also im Gegensatz zu TypeScript, wo es direkt
Teil der Grammatik ist, ist es da
fast das Gleiche, bloß über
Kommentare. Was für Python was ähnliches,
so Typen in Attributen mit reinkleben
und dann ist es irgendwo validiert.
Ganz vage an irgendwas.
Aber zumindest da habe ich
jetzt irgendwie, fange ich an, Tests
für Zeugs zu schreiben, damit ich es dann Stück für Stück ersetzen kann.
Und da hatte ich dann gestern Abend tatsächlich so ein Setup
hingekriegt, wo ich das irgendwie
von CoffeeScript mit CoffeeScript
2 Beta 5
konvertieren konnte in
modernes JavaScript, dann musste ich es nochmal durch
Babel jagen, damit ich es irgendwie
in ein anderes Modulsystem reinkriege, weil
das nicht übersetzt wurde richtig. Und dann
konnte ich in TypeScript Tests dafür schreiben.
Cool.
Sehr witzig. Das hat nur
zweimal transpilieren gebraucht.
Oder dreimal insgesamt.
Aber hey, wenn es sauber läuft, wenn man
damit eine coole neue Codebase reinkommt, ist doch wunderbar.
Auf jeden Fall. Und dann habe ich überlegt, wie
ersetze ich die einzelnen
Module? Ich habe ja da
relativ Java-esk
eine Klasse pro Datei geschrieben.
Ich dachte mir,
die Dateien kannst du Stück für Stück ersetzen.
Und du kannst es ja, ob du es nur von Coffee
nach JavaScript kopierst oder von TypeScript nach
JavaScript kompilierst, ist egal.
Aber ich könnte es sogar
methodenweise übersetzen, indem
ich
das erben lasse von dem
neuen Code, in dem
neuen Code quasi die Methoden
Stück für Stück austausche
und die dann in dem alten Code lösche.
Dann fällt das zurück auf die
geerbte neue Code-Variante.
Was sein Ansatz?
Ja, mal schauen, also wie das funktioniert.
Darüber könnte ich auch eigentlich mal wieder bloggen.
Aber es ist auch cool, wenn das Ökosystem sowas halt einfach
hergibt, dass man sowas macht.
Das ist, naja, das ist
halt kein, das ist halt nicht wirklich kompilierend.
Du übersetzt ja bloß ein JavaScript.
In einer anderen Sprache geht das
nicht. Ich könnte noch eine kurze Anekdote
von Off-Arbeit erzählen.
Wir haben so ein Monorepository,
wo ganz viel JavaScript-Zeugs drin liegt.
Ganz viele
Package-Jasons unterschiedliche, das ist alles
TypeScript-Code und das ist
in, das haben wir jetzt
zusammengeknüppert mit Learner.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du Learner kennst.
Learner ist so ein Monorepo-Verwaltungstool.
Da schreibst du in den Top-Level.
Das ist wie Workspaces, das gibt es auch bei
Cargo und
bei Yarn gibt es das jetzt auch.
Learner
hast du einfach im Top-Level,
du hast deine ganzen Node-Module
in Packages oder
Modules-Ordner.
und dann hast du oben drüber eine Learner
JSON, wo einfach die Dinger draufgeschrieben sind
und was der macht ist, dass
du dann sagst, Learner Bootstrap
und dann geht er die ganzen Dinger parallel
oder einzeln, weihnachtdem du das einstellst, durch,
installiert die ganzen Dependencies und wenn die
aufeinander dependen, dann
verknüpft er die über Softlinks.
Witzig, okay.
Klingt recht praktisch. Und das ist eigentlich
ganz cool. Wir hatten
damit ein paar Probleme, deswegen hab ich jetzt mal
rumgespielt, das auf Jahren Workspaces umzuziehen.
und da ist mir was aufgefallen,
dass wir
in den Package-JSON-Versionen,
es steht ja überall nochmal TypeScript drin,
da standen unterschiedliche TypeScript-Versionen
drin. Das heißt,
der installiert immer die
niedrigst notwendige
Version, die da drin steht.
Oder bei manchen war es festgepinnt,
da war kein Carat oder Tilde davor,
dass der eine aktuellere
Version nehmen kann. Und du warst so,
dass bis dato der unterschiedliche Code
in den unterschiedlichen Modulen mit unterschiedlichen Versionen
von TypeScript kompiliert wurde.
Was allerdings Jarn anders macht als
Learner, ist, dass es die Dependencies
hoistet. Das kannst du bei Learner auch
optional machen, aber das macht es nicht bei Default.
Jarn macht das bei Default, was heißt Hoisting.
Ich mache mir
Top-Level auch ein Node-Modules-Verzeichnis
und alles, was diese Sachen
gemeinsam haben, kopiere ich dahin und verlinke
das da. Also das
Module-Resolution von Node
funktioniert ja so, dass er, wenn er in dem Ordner, wo du gerade bist,
kein Node-Modules-Verzeichnis findet, dann
wie geht, dann geht er immer weiter hoch
und führt, bis er da eins findet. Auf die Art und Weise
hängt ganz viel von den gleichen
Dependencies ab, da ist mir aber halt
auch auf die Füße gefallen, dass plötzlich
unterschiedliche Versionen von TypeScript benutzt wurden.
Da muss ich erstmal irgendwo den Code
aktualisieren und anderen Code
reintun.
Also zumindest das TypeScript da drin
aktualisieren, weil
ich halt plötzlich nicht mehr unterschiedliche TypeScript-Varianten
nehmen konnte.
Nett. Das war ein weiteres.
Das ist ja witzig.
Naja, nett war es nicht
Also ich bin noch nicht ganz fertig
Aber das ist so, das könntest du dir
bei C++ oder bei Swift
und bei Rust absolut nicht vorstellen, dass du irgendwie
zwei unterschiedliche Sorten Code zusammenschmeißt
die mit unterschiedlichen Versionen des Compilers
gebaut wurden. Tatsächlich ist es bei Swift ja
jetzt gerade möglich mit Modul
basiert, dass halt ein Modul mit einem alten
Compiler gebaut wird
damit du halt nicht bei neuen Versionen
jetzt mehr alles umziehen musst
und jetzt wird es kommen,
dass die ABI-Stability ja unbedingt
betrifft 5, da wird mal alles komisch, aber mal schauen.
Bei Visual C++
machen sie es auch ab jetzt,
ab der aktuellsten Version,
dass jetzt irgendwie
die Compiler-ABI, glaube ich,
stabil bleibt und du
auch unterschiedliche Versionen
von dem Compiler nehmen kannst und es kompatibel
bleibt. Aber es ist schon ein bescheuertes
Problem mit ABI-Inkompatibilität.
Tja,
Das stimmt.
Wobei wir wieder bei Programmiersprachen wären.
Haben wir ja so selten angefasst, das Thema.
Ich habe manchmal das Bedenken,
dass Programmiersprachen so das Wetterthema bei Entwicklern sind.
Wenn du über nichts reden kannst,
über Programmiersprache kannst du, glaube ich, immer reden.
Oder über Kram wie Texteditoren oder Fonts.
Apropos Fonts.
Der Mick hat uns ein Issue aufgemacht in unserem Content Repo.
Hi Mick.
Und gefragt, was für Fonts wir im Editor
slash Terminal benutzen. Und er nutzt
seit neuestem Hack.
Ich habe ja nie.
Er nutzt statt Hack jetzt in Konsolata
mit diversen Patches.
In Konsolata ist das nicht das Standardding
von Mac?
Nee. Ich dachte, das war Menlo.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was der Standardform war.
Menlo ist kein Default irgendwo, glaube ich, oder?
Ich müsste schauen.
Also Hack habe ich mir angeguckt.
Hack finde ich aus irgendeinem Grund nicht schön.
Ich benutze vornehmlich
Sourcecode Pro. Doch, Millo ist der Standard
für das Mac OS Terminal.
Ja? Okay, was?
Also wie gesagt, ich stelle fast, ich habe,
das sehe ich schon gar nicht mehr, ich habe
bei meinen Terminals auch
überall immer Sourcecode Pro eingestellt.
Manchmal stelle ich Vierer Code ein im Terminal,
das ist allerdings ein bisschen... Ich wechsle auch hin und her
zwischen Vierer und
dieser neuen Font von Apple, San Francisco,
als Mono-Variante. San Francisco?
Die finde ich beide sehr schick. Das cooler an Vierer
und ähnlichen Fonts ist halt, dass sie
wie heißen sie,
Ligaturen-Support mit drin haben.
Und das ist halt besonders schick
in manchen Sprachen, gerade zum Beispiel in Swift,
wo er diesen File oft nutzt für Funktionen,
das halt zu einem Teil zusammengefasst wird
und es halt nichts kaputt geht daran. Es sieht einfach nur super schick aus.
Manche Ligaturen sind aber auch dämlich.
Also er macht
Source Good Pro
oder Fira macht aus
WWW eine Ligatur.
Das ist okay.
Aber gerade bei Operatoren finde ich es halt schön.
aber ungleich oder sowas, wo du einen schrägen
Strich durch hast. Bisschen dumm wird es halt, wenn
so ein Kommentar, so die manche Leute machen, wo du halt so
keine Ahnung, so 50 ist gleich
hintereinander packst und dann werden dich von Legaturen
von so in Dreiergrüppchen. Das sieht auch
witzigen Effekt, wenn du so Ladebalken hast.
Ja, genau.
Da fuckt das manchmal ein bisschen mit rum.
Bei Ladebalken
muss ich auch noch ein kleines
Thema zur Seite legen. Wie machen wir denn jetzt
weiter eigentlich? Ganz kurz,
Jörg hat
uns noch einen Link gegeben mit
10 most popular coding fonts.
Ich würde den einfach mit in die Show reinpacken. Ich habe ihn ehrlich gesagt nicht gelesen.
Wenn ich mir die so angucke, sehe ich
nicht wirklich große Unterschiede
zwischen einzelnen davon.
Du musst halt vergleichen, was ihr am angenehmsten
anstellt. Hier oben ist ein GIF, was
du mal durchschaltet. Also
Droid habe ich auch.
Droid-Sans ist auch echt der schicke Font, muss ich sagen.
Vera ist auch auf Linux, glaube ich,
Default, aber ist eigentlich auch wirklich schön.
Das Ubuntu finde ich...
Das Ubuntu wirkt halt hart nach Ubuntu.
Anonymous ist mir neu.
Vira auf jeden Fall. M Plus kenne ich gar nicht.
Deja Vu ist auch so ein Standard
in Konsolata. Das glaube ich auch ein Standard.
Das muss ich noch ausprobieren.
Ihr stellt jetzt mal alle eure Texteditoren
ein und schreibt uns dann bitte auf Twitter,
welche ihr am schönsten findet.
Ich habe letztens einen interessanten Post auf Hacker News gelesen.
Da hat jemand advocated
tatsächlich für seinen Code
keine Monospace-Font mehr zu nehmen.
Ich habe mir
das Reasoning nicht ganz komplett
zu Herzen gefühlt. Es klang nicht ganz
blöd, aber ich finde
einfach, dass sie zu falsch sind.
Ja, das ist ziemlich dumm vor allem.
Wenn du dann noch sagst, und ich nehme übliche Tabs,
dann sind ja alle Bats off,
dann hast du überhaupt kein Alignment mehr.
Ich glaube, er hat irgendeine Sprache genommen, wo Alignment nur so Nebensache
ist, dass du das halt nicht so
relevant bist. In welcher Sprache ist ein Alignment?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Also, ich muss das nochmal
raussuchen.
Da fällt mir ein, wenn eine Sprache, eine Font, die hier nicht
auftaucht, ist diese komische Go-Font.
Es gibt eine Font für Go? Ja, klar.
es gibt eine GoFund, die ist sogar auf Golang irgendwo
mal in eine Blogpost aufgetaucht.
Da hast du dann schöne Code-Beispiele gesehen.
Das war schwarzer Text auf weißem Hintergrund.
Sowieso.
Also sagen, ich habe
Syntax-Teilex für Kinder, aber es ist eine eigene Schriftart ausdenken.
Dann hast du dir das angeguckt, das war so eine
Serifenschrift und das sah so ein bisschen urig aus.
Es sah echt aus. Ich habe mir den Code
angeguckt, das sieht aus wie so ein altes
Fax.
Ich glaube, das war auch daran angelehnt, das sah aus
wie so ein Code-Beispiel aus diesem original
C-Programming-Language-Buch.
Sehr ähnlich an Kurier.
Ja, ein bisschen runder, glaube ich,
noch irgendwie. Das war weird.
Da denken sie sich
ihre eigene
Schriftart aus.
Ich möchte echt mal wissen,
wenn einer von euch dabei ist,
es hören ja ein paar Leute, die Go
machen, benutzt ihr wirklich
kein Syntax-Highlighting?
Keiner, der irgendwie
heutzutage Code schreibt, außer diesen komischen Go-Maintainern,
Nutzt Syntax-Highlighting.
Jeder, meine ich.
Ja, keiner nutzt kein Syntax-Highlighting.
Ich kann mich nicht vorstellen, aber ich meine, das macht so viel her.
Das ist so wichtig, um eine Struktur direkt
auf den ersten Blick zu erkennen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube, du musst schon halber Autist sein,
um in der Lage zu sein, Code optisch
zu pausen ohne Syntax-Highlighting.
Ich starte die ganze Zeit einfach dieses GIF hier an,
von dem die Links, wo die Fonts einfach durchgeschaltet werden.
Es ist kein aktuelles Sublime.
Sublime 3 kam raus vor ein paar Tagen.
Die haben jetzt so chromartige
Tabs. Die sind einfach schicker, weil sie nicht mehr
so runde Kanten haben, sondern
kantig. Ich benutze jetzt übrigens schon
seit einiger Zeit
Firefox 57 Nightly.
Auch um mich mal dran zu gewöhnen, dass halt
diese ganzen Add-ons weggehen.
Es sind echt viele Add-ons nicht mehr da.
Aber es hat ein paar Features,
die schön sind. Du kannst jetzt, also ich weiß nicht,
ob das bleibt, das ist so ein
Test-Pilot-Feature. Du kannst jetzt hier
auf diesen Plus-Tab-
Plus-Button länger hältst,
kannst du Container
vergeben. Da kannst du quasi
unterschiedliche Profile in einem Profil haben
für bestimmte Anwendungen. Das heißt,
du hast Banking,
Personal Work
und Shopping und dann werden die ganzen
Einstellungen, ich weiß nicht Einstellungen, aber
Cookies und Passwörter und
Formdaten getrennt
gehalten. Das ist cool.
Da gab es nicht irgendein komisches
Feature daran, dass das neues Tab
irgendwie in einem Default-Container aufgeht?
Ja, genau. Wenn du es nicht benutzt,
dann sind halt alle im Gleichen.
Du kannst ja auch die selber noch
managen, neu hinzufügen. Aber ne, finde ich schön.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen eingelernt an Tab-Gruppen,
was mal ein richtig geiles Feature war.
Ja, das werde ich echt vermissen.
Dafür werde ich halt fünf Firefox-Fenster aufhaben
oder sowas in Zukunft. Das Problem ist,
ich habe halt immer nur ein Browser-Fenster mit
zigtausend Tabs, weil ich
die-hard-Safari-Nutzer bin.
Und das Problem ist, wenn ich Safari
kille, dann kann ich
nur das ein Fenster, das
Fenster wiederherstellen. Und mir ist es
schon ein paar Mal passiert, dass ich halt ein aufwesendendes
Safari-Fenster aufmache und
dann töte ich das Fenster mit meinen ganzen
Tabs dran. Und da komme ich
halt nicht mehr ran. Die sind halt weg. Ich habe die Tabs ja auch nicht
in der einen Session aufgemacht, sondern die sind teilweise seit Monaten
offen. Und da kann ich in der History, weiß ich ja nicht,
wo die geöffnet wurden. Ja, also ich habe dieses
Tab-Panorama von Firefox extrem
genutzt. Da gehst du mal kurz mit
mit
Störung, Shift, E
raus und dann kannst du halt so semantische Gruppen
aus Tabs bauen.
und das ist echt ein super Feature.
Ich nutze auch auf KDE
Activities sehr stark.
Ich finde es wichtig, dass man nochmal eine weitere
Abstraktionsebene bei solchen
Sachen hat. Einfach bloß alle Tabs
in einer Liste
sequenziell
nacheinander. Das ist fürchterlich.
So, wir wurden gerade ein bisschen unterbrochen
und sind jetzt reingegangen
und deswegen ist wahrscheinlich auch unsere Akustik
jetzt ein bisschen anders.
Und gerade eben, als ich die letzten zwei Minuten nochmal
gehört habe, die wir gerade gesprochen haben, wir waren
ein bisschen unstrukturiert.
Aber wir haben noch Themen vorbereitet. Lass uns mal über Sachen reden.
Es sind so viele Sachen passiert,
seitdem wir die letzte Folge aufgenommen haben.
Wann immer mal das gewesen sein soll.
Das weiß ich nicht, wo ich nicht her ist.
Das kann niemand mehr nachprüfen.
Zum Beispiel gab es
Angriffe über NPM-Pakete.
Stimmt.
Da gab es ein witziges, also es ging ein bisschen
um den Internet-Globus,
dass es ein NPM-Package gibt, was
ich meine, das hieß wie ein
populäres Package, nur mit einem Typo.
und nicht nur eins, da gab es
relativ viele.
Es ist halt populär geworden,
da mal reinzuschauen. Das hat einfach
dein Quiddus Environment gescannt und das
gepostet an irgendein Web-Service.
Also da stand irgendwo in diesen
Node-Packages, da stehen ja
Skripte drin, install, post-install,
pre-install
und da stand in dem post-install
stand
curlx, irgendeine Environment-Variable
an dem Web-Service.
Ich habe immer alles gecheckt, ob da irgendwo
welche Keys mit drin sind, Authentication-Daten,
was auch immer, Dinge, die man halt
in Enfas speichert.
Und das ist halt besonders fies, weil das sind halt
diese Post-Install- oder Print-Stall-Skripte,
die werden halt ausgeführt beim Installieren,
also auf dem Laptop oder
auf dem Rechner des Entwicklers, wenn der
diese Dependency mit reinzieht.
Und es gab auch schon Fälle, da wurden Dependency-Packages
gekauft von anderen, um da Scheiße
mitzumachen.
Oder halt hier die Übertypos.
von Duo, ich weiß gar nicht mehr ehrlich gesagt,
wer das genau ist oder was die machen,
aber die haben mal ein bisschen umhergeschaut
und ein paar NPM-Packages oder
gefühlt eigentlich alle NPM-Package analysiert
und geschaut, was da so für Sachen so gemacht werden
und haben ein paar Sachen gefunden,
die einerseits Proof of Concept sind,
die einfach beim Post-Install
dir ausgeben, hey,
danke, dass wir da gerade alles von dir klauen durften
und so weiter oder
diese witzige Kommando say auf einem Mac
ausnutzen, der einfach dann laut Dinge sagt,
wenn du deinen Ton anerlässt.
Dann gibt es Packages, die tatsächlich
einen Curl an Google Analytics
oder so weitermachen oder an PIVX oder was auch.
Und mit Tracking-1 werden sie installiert,
obwohl NPM schon diverser Zeit sammelt.
Aber das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen eklig.
Und dann gibt es natürlich die Packages, die wirklich
bösen Kram machen. Wie zum Beispiel,
was besonders mies ist, ist zum Beispiel dieses Package
Mr. Robot, was diesen
Hex-Aski-Schrug-Emoji,
wie man diese Dinger nennt,
an deine Log-Messages mit ranhängt. Das ist der ganze Sinn
des NPM-Packages. Ein absolut sinnvolles Package, by the way.
aber in seinem Post-Install
packt das zu jedem Package,
nutzt das NPM auf der CLI,
um zu jedem Package, was dir gehört,
den Owner von dem Package
Mr. Robot, der auch Mr. Robot heißt,
hinzuzufügen als Owner.
Und somit hast du direkt mal alle deine Packages
geowned an der Hälfte.
Sobald das das nächste Mal
publisht, ist der mit einer der Owner.
Sobald du das installiert hast, ist der der Owner.
NPM macht das ja dir,
die schickt dir ja direkt als Collaborator
mit dem Owner hinzu.
Ja, also NPM-Skripts sind an und für sich eine scheiße Idee,
aber du kannst da auch irgendwie nicht mehr abschalten,
ohne eine ganze Menge Infrastruktur damit kaputt zu machen erst mal.
Sowas in der Art wird halt auch gebraucht.
Du musst teilweise Post-and-Stop-Re-Store-Dinge ausführen können.
Aber da ist halt die Frage,
sowas muss in erster Linie auf jeden Fall die Sandbox sein.
Wie viel muss das können, genau.
Ich weiß, dass es auf Twitter hin und her ging
und da hat einer geschrieben, hier, guckt mal, NPM-Leute.
Das und das habe ich gefunden.
Die Pakete, die heißen alle so ähnlich wie das,
aber ohne Strich oder mit Strich und so weiter und so fort.
Und da habe ich unten drunter geschrieben,
kann man das nicht irgendwie sandboxen?
Und da ist einer hingegangen und hat gesagt,
ja, guck mal, schau mal, was ich machen kann,
ob man das irgendwie sandboxen kann.
Du kannst ja da drin jedes Bash-Skript,
andere JavaScript-Sateien ausführen.
Das ist schon...
Das soll nicht so sein.
Es gibt zwar Services,
war das beim ChangeLog,
im Interview mit dem Haupttypen von NPM,
gibt es auch Services, die sich da drüber laufen lassen,
um das irgendwie zu sanitizen,
aber wenn den so was entgeht, dann ist das natürlich
ein großes Problem. Also eigentlich sollte
so ein Postman-Starscript
keinen Zugriff auf
Dateisystem oder
Environment-Variable haben.
Und dann nutzt es natürlich häufig, um irgendwie nochmal
deinen Transpiler
drüber zu jagen über deinen
JavaScript, aber
der sollte dann wirklich nichts anderes machen können,
außer vielleicht diesen einen
Source-Code-Ordner lesen und einen anderen Ordner schreiben können.
Ja, obwohl das schon manchmal
tricky, beziehungsweise brauchst du in manchen
vielleicht sogar mehr als das oder willst du haben,
aber dann wird es halt echt frieren.
Das ist einfach fundamental
kaputt. NPM ist kein Build-System.
Es wird aber mit diesen Skripten als
Build-System verwendet und es hat
lange Zeit gut funktioniert,
dadurch, dass NPM
einfach bloß das Zeugs runtergeladen und in einen
Ordner geschmissen war, es fertig.
Und als dann Leute angefangen haben,
mit
sowas wie CoffeeScript oder TypeScript oder mit
Babel anzufangen vorzuschreiben,
wo du nochmal mit einem Tool drüber gehen musst,
wo du es bearbeiten, benutzen kannst.
Du hattest das Bedürfnis,
NPM wie ein Build-System zu benutzen.
Und dann kannst du aber,
ich habe ja gerade über Jahren und Learner gerettet,
da rennst du halt in allerhand Probleme rein,
wo dann Sachen,
NPM ist ja kein Make,
das achtet nicht darauf,
ob eine bestimmte Reihenfolge eingehalten wird,
ob bestimmte Dependencies fertig sind.
Das ist scheiße.
Ja, ich meine, das stimmt schon.
Aber Interesse haben wir,
Wie macht denn das Rust zum Beispiel?
Du kannst ja auch da in der Builder-S
mit reinhauen in deine Cargo-Tommel,
die ja erstmal nicht ausführbar ist,
sondern der Kram, der halt
ausgeführt wird, ist das irgendwo gesandboxt
oder wie wird das gehandhabt?
Das ist eine gute Frage, das weiß ich gar nicht so genau.
Normalerweise,
wenn in einer von diesen Communities
so ein Aufschrei losgeht, dann werden alle
anderen erstmal kurz aufmerksam.
Bei
Kick, nee, wie heißt das?
Bei Left-Pads, bei dem Left-Pad-Incident,
In NPM haben alle anderen erstmal gesagt, oh, bei uns hätte das auch passieren können.
Und die Cargo-Leute haben gesagt, bei uns hätte das nicht passieren können.
Aber an der Stelle habe ich da nichts mitbekommen.
Das müssen wir nochmal nachgucken.
Das Problem haben ja viele andere.
Aber normalerweise, wenn ich genau hinüberlege, ist so ein
Bild-RS-Skript
erstmal ein vollwertiges
Rust-Programm, was ausgeführt wird.
Ja klar, aber halt auch lokal auf der Maschine des Entwicklers
und wird halt beim Bauen mit ausgeführt.
Genau, wird als erstes gebaut und dann ausgeführt.
Jedenfalls nicht beim Runterladen, sowohl wie auch NPM.
bei der npm install ist ja
der Command, der quasi das Paket runterlädt
und dann die Install Hooks eben mit ausführt.
Ja, aber das ist dir in dem Fall egal.
Es macht keinen großen Unterschied, klar.
Aber es macht ein bisschen Unterschied. Also wenn du
den Compile-Vorgang, keine Ahnung,
nicht lokal ausführst, zumindest in
einem Container oder in einer VM,
dann macht es nochmal ein bisschen Unterschied,
aber du hast ihn natürlich trotzdem vulnerable für
diverse Sachen. Also wenn du vielleicht
einen Vime-Variablen speichern, viele Leute
Kram, der dir nicht daraus soll,
API-Keys, auch Daten, wie auch immer, wie schon genannt.
Also ich
habe mal nach ein paar Stichworten gerade
hier die Doku durchsucht zu Build-Skripten
in Rust, aber das ist natürlich eine interessante Frage.
Ja, zum Beispiel Ruby hatte das selbe Problem,
da gab es ja auch einen Post, den habe ich einfach mal mit den Journals gepackt,
da stehe ich nicht viel dabei, dass Ruby-Gems
ja auch quasi ähnliche Hooks haben und du kannst
da auf die ähnliche Art und Weise
Mist machen.
Ich persönlich kenne jetzt
Swift an der Stelle, wo das natürlich
genau dasselbe ist, obwohl es da seit schon
langer Zeit immerhin gesandboxed ist.
Dann wird es ja noch schwieriger, wenn
dein
Manifestformat bereits ausführbar ist.
Da gibt es gar nicht den Standard
im Sinne von, es gibt das
direkt passbar, aber ich glaube, da habe ich letztes Mal schon drüber
gerangt.
Aber es ist halt direkt ausführbar,
aber immerhin kannst du da halt nicht
Dinge ändern. Das war ja auch ein Problem, wo ich
reingerannt bin, weil ich da ja aus der
Reviment Dinge reinpacken wollte
und meine Source-Dateien eigentlich umschreiben wollte, obwohl ich in dem
im Verzeichnis war.
Vielleicht war das ja, das sind Wocking vielleicht auch nicht.
Ja, das war so eine der Geschichten, die
die Jahreskriptwelt bewegt haben, seitdem wir
unsere letzte Folge aufgenommen haben.
Ein anderes war, dass
Node.js zwischendurch geforkt wurde.
Stimmt, ja.
Es gab IO.js.
Nee, IO ist das andere gewesen.
Es heißt aber IO.js.
Ach stimmt, das sieht ja aus.
A, Y, O oder so.
Es schrubbt sich komplett anders.
Es sprach sich aber
trotzdem IOJS aus.
Ich weiß nicht,
ist die Geschichte mit dem ersten IOJS
bekannt? Ich weiß bloß, dass es mal
diesen Vorgab. Ich weiß nicht mehr,
aus welchem Grund der... Doch, weil die irgendwie
lizenzrechtlich ist und wer
da Contributions machen darf.
Es war aufsächlich die Sache, dass
Node.js irgendwie stagniert
ist in der Entwicklung und
es dann Streit darüber gab, welche
neuen Änderungen da drin vorgenommen werden.
Es gab halt die Leute, die schneller auf die
aktuellste V8-Version updaten wollten
und auch die API schneller weiter
entwickelt haben. Und die haben dann einen Fork gemacht
und den IOGS genannt. Und der ist dann
von Version 0.10
Punkt irgendwas, was
Node.js damals hatte, ist der relativ schnell
auf Version 1, 2, 3, 4,
5. Und
dann kam irgendwie, ich habe
jetzt die Chronologie wahrscheinlich durcheinander geworfen,
war Node.js immer noch bei 0.12
irgendwas. Und irgendwann haben sie
dann die schlaue Entscheidung getroffen,
zusammenzuschmeißen und es wieder zu merchen.
und dann dementsprechend hat
Node.js diesen plötzlichen Sprung
auf Node.js 4 oder 5 oder 6
gemacht
kurz vor dem Vork hatte ich
damals noch Node-Krams zu machen
und lange Zeit nicht mehr, das habe ich gerade noch mitbekommen gehabt
genau und jetzt kommen relativ
schnell nacheinander Major-Versionen
von Node.js aus
und was war jetzt mit dem neuen I.O.JS?
das ist was anderes gewesen
das war jetzt so eine politische Entscheidung
und zwar gab es einen sehr zentralen
oder Mitarbeiter vom Core-Team von Node.js,
der sich nicht an den Code of Conduct gehalten hat
und wie ein bisschen arschig in Kommentaren war
oder keine Ahnung was genau, weiß ich nicht so richtig.
Und es wurden einfach keine Konsequenzen gezogen
und da haben sich Leute beschwert,
dass sich jemand offensichtlich nicht an den Code of Conduct hält,
aber dass das Steering Committee nicht darauf reagiert.
und da hat man so einen politischen Fork gemacht.
Da haben sie einfach mal den Code
auf GitHub geforkt
und gesagt, so, wir machen
jetzt hier Node.js weiter unter
IO.js, diesmal anders geschrieben und
hier wird sich aber an den Code of Conduct gehalten.
Das hat auch
bloß eine Woche oder zwei gehalten. War auch nicht, glaube ich,
ernsthaft eine Absicht, da das
Projekt abzuzweigen.
Für das alte IO.js
gab es ja wirklich eine Webseite und eigenes
Artwork. Das war ja auch ein paar Monate
da war wirklich abzusehen,
dass Leute von
Node.js auf IOH.js wechseln.
Aber bei dem jetzt war das wirklich
eher so ein Statement.
Ja, aber das Statement an sich war ja nicht falsch.
Nee, das ist komplett richtig.
Also allgemein der Begriff Code of Conduct
ist ja auch was, was in den letzten Jahren immer wichtiger wird.
Ganz viele Konferenzen
veröffentlichen auf ihrer Seite,
ein COC, eine Unterseite.
Es gibt den,
das können wir mal in die Show Notes tun, es gibt den
Berlin Code of Conduct,
der für viele Events, die in Berlin stattfinden,
so als Template
genommen werden kann.
Und da steht dann sowas drin.
Ist das Berlin-spezifisch?
Nee, ist nichts.
Also in dem Text selber ist nichts Berlin-spezifisches drin.
Da steht
hauptsächlich drin,
A primary goal of all the conferences
and user groups
that refer to this
code of conduct is to be inclusive
to the largest number of
contributors with the most
varied and diverse backgrounds possible. As such, we are committed to providing a friendly,
safe and welcoming environment for all regards of gender, sexual orientation, ability, ethnicity,
socioeconomic status and religion or the lack thereof. This code of conduct outlines our
expectations for all those who participate in our community as well as the consequences for
unacceptable behavior.
Then is this here.
There's some powerpunkte definiert
open source culture tech
citizenship.
Expected behavior
unacceptable behavior
consequences of
from any community member
including sponsors and those
with decision making authority
will not be tolerated.
Anyone asked to stop unacceptable behavior is expected to comply immediately.
Und das ist halt an der Stelle,
der Code of Conduct von Node.js ist nicht eins zu eins der gleiche,
aber da wird wahrscheinlich genau sowas passiert sein.
Die Grundidee ist ja einfach, möglichst inklusiv zu sein
und Leute, die sich beschissen verhalten,
mit einer Rechtsgrundlage.
Hier steht, dass das, was du gerade machst, beschissen ist.
Es ist einfach nur eine neue Form von agreement.
bei Code gab es schon lange
Lizenzen und hier gibt es halt
nochmal so eine Verhaltenslizenz
so, da steht einfach bloß
relativ offensichtliches Völkstum, zumindest
für die meisten, just don't be an asshole.
Und wir achten darauf und es wird
Konsequenzen geben und das ist wichtig.
Ist das nicht mehr oder weniger der Code of Conduct vom
Chaos Communication Congress to learn to each other
und einfach das ist der Code of Conduct?
Das ist genau, es ist
halt ein bisschen schwammig.
Hier ist es schon ganz gut.
Solche Sachen hätte man früher als gesunden
Menschenverstand abgestempelt, aber es gibt halt
Ja, aber das mit dem besonderen Menschenverstand geht halt
allgemein wieder zurück in letzter Zeit,
finde ich mal so. Ja, vielleicht ist es das und deshalb wird so etwas
relevanter. Interessanterweise,
ich glaube,
hier ist bei dem
Berlin Code of Conduct ist der
Florian Gilcher mit
beteiligt und der hat mich neulich mal
angeschrieben, du kennst dich doch in Dresden
aus, es gibt jetzt einen Dresden Code of Conduct.
Was ist an dem so anders?
Und ob ich
damit was zu tun habe oder die Leute, die das
Ich weiß gar nicht, was genau.
Oder ist quasi verbatim übernommen.
Deswegen finde ich es witzig, dass
beim Berlin Code of Conduct
der letzte Punkt nach
Unacceptable Behavior,
Consequences of Unacceptable Behavior,
bla bla bla bla, Scope is
License and Attribution.
Und da steht halt hier
Creative Commons Attribution.
Und das ist 1 zu 1
hier auch nochmal drin.
Ah ja, hier steht
Thanks to the maintainers, friends and community
of the Berlin Code of Conduct for
Translations and Revisions.
Warum ist das jetzt? Könnte man ja nicht was Allgemeinheites
draus machen, warum muss man jetzt auf
Stadtebene? Keine Ahnung.
Man könnte auf jeder Strukturebene, ich glaube ich,
gerne einen ASCII Code of Conduct und einen
Christen-Neustadt-Code of Conduct.
ASCII Code of Conduct.
Ja,
das bringt ja jetzt nicht, aber ich meine, es ist schön
irgendwo was zu haben, wo man hinzeigen kann,
aber dann lieber callofconduct.org
slash Sprache oder so.
Das wäre natürlich cool, allerdings
frage ich mich, warum man überhaupt
unterscheiden muss bei Code of Conduct.
Also du könntest dir jetzt überlegen,
sowas wie Creative Commons
für Code of Conduct und dann hast du
dann so eine zentrale Stelle, auf die du
verweisen kannst und machst du bei deiner Veranstaltung
nur noch so Icons hin.
Oder bestimmte Subsets von Regeln
oder sowas. Aber dann
fragst du dich halt, warum
gibt es nicht ein Code of Conduct,
wie sich alle Menschen verhalten?
Ja, so wie ich es verstehe, ist das ja alles quasi
die sehr verbose Form
Be Excellent, Türi Scharre.
Und es ist ja auch schön, dass es so ist.
Und ich fände es sehr komisch, wenn ich auf einer Veranstaltung
oder was auch immer für eine Sache dahin gehe
und dann sehe ich, oh, hier fehlt dieses eine Icon.
Warum ist das hier denn ausgenommen?
Das wäre einfach nur weird. Prinzipiell
wollen doch quasi die meisten
ihren eigenen Code of Conduct. Ich kann mir kaum vorstellen, dass ich jetzt
zu einer Nazi-Demo gehe und plötzlich
haben die ein Code of Conduct, wo drinsteht, dass du
gegen diese Gruppen von Menschen sehr feindlich
sein musst. Das wäre weird, wenn
die sowas rauspacken.
Ein Code of Conduct für mich ist einfach generell dieses
dieselbe Formulierung überall und sie ist einfach
da, weil es gut ist, wenn sie da steht,
weil dann hat man was, worauf man sich berufen kann.
Das würde mich wundern, wenn irgendwelche Nazi-Veranstaltungen
oder vielleicht AfD-Kongresse plötzlich einen Code
of Conduct haben.
Die AfD könnte vielleicht einen Code of Conduct haben, aber
da steht halt wahrscheinlich nicht drin,
dass man gegenüber allen Religionen
oder Nicht-Religionen
aufgeschlossen einbringt.
Tja.
Aber ja, warum wir genau einen Dresden
Code of Conduct haben, wahrscheinlich einfach,
auch nochmal für,
auf dem anderen steht halt Berlin.
Das ist halt auch komisches Syllett.
Hier in Dresden gibt übrigens der Berliner Code of Conduct,
da haben sie es einfach nochmal abgeschrieben und gesagt,
hier, guck mal, es ist das gleiche Geld, der noch bei uns.
Komisch. Aber es ist halt von der,
ja. Das sind das Poster,
das ist ein Download-Poster-Button,
wie schaut es aus? Da ist ein Dresden-Logo
irgendwie drauf und dann
ein Dresden-Logo oben, Dresden-Community,
Dresden-Logo, also das Dresdner-Wappen.
Ja, das ist hier dresden-co-
auf-conduct.org
und das andere ist
BerlinCodeOfConduct.org
komplett ohne Striche. Das hätten sie mal
einheitlich machen können.
Selbst da schon scheitert.
Da könntest du jetzt gleich eine Angriffe drauf fahren,
wie auf NPM. Machst jetzt nämlich
eine Webseite, die heißt DresdenCodeOfConduct
ohne Bindestriche, wenn sie das nicht schon längst
weiterleiten. Und da stehen dann einfach diverse Ausnahmen.
Und da stehen dann Ausnahmen drin,
dass du nämlich Leute aufgrund von
Tabs und Spaces Unterscheidungen diskriminieren
darfst.
Ja, eigentlich diesen Tweet, ich fand den so großartig
letztens, wenn wir schon ganz kurz bei Tabs
und Spaces sind, ich will einfach nur das mit einwerfen,
ich finde ihn wunderschön.
Spaces have different semantic meanings.
Spaces say, I want to indent this code.
Tabs say, I am a monster.
Ja, stimmt.
Wunderschön.
Das wollte ich eigentlich erst nachher bei den
GitHub-Stars erwähnen, aber ich habe
nördlich auch noch so ein Blogpost gesehen.
Writing
Command-Line-Applications in Rust.
war das so ein kleines Beispiel, da hatte einer
W-Get neu gebaut. Das war
relativ einfach, der hat hier dieses
Request genommen, diese Library, wo
er nicht mehr viel machen muss, einfach ein bisschen Kommandozeilen
Interface drum gebaut. Und das
habe ich mir installiert und habe das mal angeguckt,
habe das über Cargo installiert,
R-Get, und fand das cool, weil das halt
gleichzeitig noch so
Multiplexer war, das heißt, der hat einfach
Endverbindungen gleichzeitig aufgemacht,
in Dateien schon und die zum Schluss gemerged.
Dann habe ich mir gedacht, ja, cool,
aber dann wollte ich von der Seite was runterladen,
wo ich so ein bisschen
Authentifizierung brauchte und Passwort angeben
musste und das hat das Ding nicht gekonnt
dachte ich mir, na gut, okay, dann clone ich mir den Code
jetzt, hab ich mir den Blogpost angeguckt, dann hab ich da dran
angefangen rumzuhacken und dann hab ich da
Authentification eingebaut
muss ja auch bloß die
Sachen weiterleiten
dann baue ich das, dann führe ich das aus und dann merke ich, dass es irgendwie anders
aussieht als das, was ich mir vorher über Cargo installiert
habe, dann gucke ich mir auch nochmal auf die
Cargo-Seite unter Agert und stelle fest, dass es ein komplett anderes
Programm ist
Na toll.
Es gibt also zwei
R-Gets
und
dann habe ich das einfach bei dem anderen auch nochmal gemacht,
weil es fast identisch ist, wirklich.
Es unterscheidet sich kaum.
Kommen Sie mit einem Typen?
Nee, es sind zwei Typen.
Das eine ist, wo ich als erstes dran gearbeitet habe,
war wirklich relativ fürchterlich geschrieben.
Da gab es eine ganze Menge zu Refactor
und so zu machen. Das andere hat aber das Problem,
dass
die Eindruckung, die der Typ als Standard gewählt hatte,
drei Spaces waren.
Ja, ich mag das. Drei oder fünf
oder generell ungerade Zahlen.
Ihr seid meine Helden.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, what the fuck.
Da habe ich immer
dann getippt, tap getippt,
da musste ich immer ein Zeichen löschen.
Das hat nicht funktioniert. Dann habe ich kurz überlegt,
ob ich die Eistörung beim Editor ändere, um das durchzuziehen.
Ich habe mir gedacht, nee, das mache ich jetzt nicht.
Dann habe ich mich da so ein bisschen durchgequemt.
Weil ich kurz davor eben irgendwie
in den PR, den ich dann geschickt habe,
hier zu sagen, guck mal, alle anderen machen auch
4 Spaces. Ich hab das jetzt mal hier auf 4
Spaces umgestellt, aber ich find das immer ziemlich
assi, wenn jemand PR macht
und eine Sache
quasi anders und gleichzeitig
alles andere auch noch anders. Oder generell solche
projektweiten Sachen, die sollst
du dir nicht ausführen im PR.
Das kannst du gerne mit dem Interner besprechen
und dann kann er das selber ändern, aber
das ist nichts, was du als Externer da zu
entscheiden hast. Genau. Und ich hab ihm dann
geschrieben, hi, ich find
dein Tool cool, ich benutze es auch jetzt,
aber ich wollte halt noch
Passwort- und
Benutzername-Funktionalität einbauen, das habe ich
gemacht. In dem Zusammenhang habe ich übrigens auch noch
die eine Dependency-Lage updated,
diese HTTP-Library, musste man halt
ein bisschen was und das habe ich auch gemacht. Und dann
habe ich auch noch, weil eine Zertifikat
ich etwas runterladen wollte, kein
kein
valides Zertifikat hat,
habe ich dann noch diese, wie sie auch bei Curl und
WGit gibt, diese Insecure-Parameter
gemacht, so an der Stelle.
Und das habe ich mir alles geschrieben. Und da schreibt der Post
unter, er gibt die Squash-Kommets
und ich sage, ich bleibe
jetzt freundlich. Ich schreibe
jetzt, klar, mache ich doch
gerne. Ich finde sowas schade. Also bei manchen
Web-Bus ergibt es Sinn, Kommets zu squashen, aber gerade
bei Contributions, bei Projekten, wo es
halt nicht irgendwie einen Grund gibt.
Warum denn squashen? Das machst du einfach nur,
gerade wenn man verschiedene Dinge gemacht hat
in einem PR, wirklich Dinge, die von einer abgetrennt
sind, dann pack das doch in einzelnen Kommets und lass das
genauso drin.
Außerdem hat er einen fucking Button in der UI
getappt, das für ihn macht.
Da steht da Squash and Merge.
Und dann, egal.
Naja, das war auch so ein Tool,
das malt sich dann in die Kommandozeile
so ein Progress Bar.
Schön.
Und das zuckt so witzig,
wenn du Legatoren anhast.
Achso.
Weil dann ist immer,
wenn ein Vierfaches von 3 ist,
gleich da ist,
dann wird das wieder so komprimiert,
so ein Lang ist gleich.
Ja.
Sollten wir eigentlich Bullshit-Sans
erwähnen, wenn wir schon bei Ligaturen-Font sind?
Bullshit-Sons. Das war diese wunderschöne
Font, die als Ligaturen reingehackt
diverse Bullshit
Enterprise-Begriffe
mit drin hatte. Du solltest du nicht auf deinem
Laptop installieren, wenn du irgendwie
Bewerbungsgespräche oder Vorträge
von...
Da gehst du auf die Webseite.
Ich habe mich schon mal verwundert, dass das plötzlich noch irgendwo
Bullshit auftaucht auf der Webseite von
Irgendwem. Was die Font halt macht ist,
die hat halt auch Ligaturen drin,
beziehungsweise sind halt keine Ligaturen, also sind schon Ligaturen,
aber keine Ligaturen. Wir sollten vielleicht mal kurz erzählen, was eine Ligaturen
ist, wenn du
jetzt was schreibst und ursprünglich
im Handschriftlichen ist es ja so, dass du
bestimmte Zahlen, also Zeichenkombinationen
ein bisschen anders schreibst. Also
wenn du ein C schreibst und ein H schreibst,
schreibst du CH, also ein bisschen anders.
Oder SCH. Und
früher, als man noch schön geschrieben hat,
hat zum Beispiel FF so ein bisschen aneinander geschrieben.
Und das gibt es auch
in Schriftorten und das ist einfach
die Regel, wenn bestimmte Zeichenfolgen, da kann man
frei angeben, wenn bestimmte
Zeichenfolgen kommt, dann schreibt bitte nicht
diese Zeichenfolge, sondern
schreibt bitte dieses spezielle Zeichenschnitt,
das soll man machen. Und manche Schriftdaten schlangen mit so etwas
wie FF oder sowas.
Und jetzt gibt es halt Codings, die machen das
mit bestimmten
Keywords und bestimmten Zeichenkombinationen, die
in das Quelltext 4 auftauchen, nämlich zum Beispiel
so Operatoren
istgleich, istgleich zusammengezogen
oder Ausrufezeichen istgleich
wird zu so einem mathematischen istgleich mit einem
schrägen Strich durchgemacht.
Andere Operatoren werden kombiniert
Sieht eigentlich meistens ziemlich schick aus.
Und man kann allerdings auch Sachen zu Ligatoren erklären,
die ganze Worte sind.
Zum Beispiel Cloud oder Synergy.
Und anstattdessen einfach ein langes Zeichen rein.
Das wieder ein Wort ist, wo einfach dann Bullshit steht.
Und da ist eine Schriftart, die aus validem Text Bullshit macht.
Hier sieht man ein GIF, wo einer was tippt
und dann wird ein Wort zu Ende draus geschrieben.
Zum Beispiel, was stand da?
Agile Cloud.
Ja, sobald das ausgetippt, dann wird da Bullshit raus.
Und our BS App saves our Bullshit in Bullshit
and creates a Bullfucking Shit.
Bullfucking Shit war Paradigm Shift.
Bullshit.
Wunderschön.
Sand, Bullshit, Sand.
Komm, ich packe es nicht, ich schaue los.
Was es dann auch noch gibt, ist Block.
Das ist natürlich was ganz anderes,
hat überhaupt mit diesen Plikaturen zu tun,
so eine Schriftart, wo hier das Zeichen einfach so ein Quadrat ist
oder ein schwarzer Block ist.
Zensurmäßig.
Zensurmäßig, sodass du das alles
geschwärzt ist. Aber du kannst es halt kopieren,
wenn du die Schriftart wechselst, dann hast du die Daten
noch da. Stark.
Das ist ja cool.
Das gefällt mir.
Witziger Anders dafür.
Das hatte ich in meiner Diplomarbeit in der Grafik
gemacht. Da hatte ich so ein bisschen Zeugs gemockt und was
reingeschrieben, was ich vorher kopiert hatte.
Dann dachte ich mir, ich mache mal einfach diese
Blog-Schriftart drauf. Dann habe ich das in SVG
umgewandelt und meine PDF
von meiner Diplomarbeit eingebettet.
Und irgendwann dachte ich mir,
ich probiere es mal aus.
Und dann konnte ich tatsächlich den Text von meinen Grafiken,
wo bloß schwarze Zeilen waren,
konnte ich kopieren und woanders reinpricht.
Da dachte ich mir, fuck, jetzt muss die ganze Grafik drauf.
Schriftart sind was Feines.
Das hat schon Spaß mit da.
Was ist denn noch so passiert?
Wir sitzen jetzt im ASCII.
Ja.
Und ich war neulich auf Klassenfahrt.
Darauf gehe ich gleich ein.
Aber auf der Klassenfahrt hatte ich
habe ich mich nochmal mit Leuten über Podcasts
unterhalten und mir ist ein schöner Podcast
wieder eingefallen, den ich selber
seit einiger Zeit nicht abonniert hatte,
als ich die mir überfohlen habe und dann habe ich die selber
wieder abonniert. Request
for Comments. Das ist
ein deutscher Podcast.
Kann ich eigentlich machen?
Ein deutscher Podcast?
Podcast.
Und da werden
so IETF-RFCs
besprochen.
Das ist,
Ich suche gerade den Namen von der Moderatorin,
die heißt Anna oder Anna...
Lena.
Anna-Lena.
Und die ersten Folgen hat sie ziemlich häufig einfach
Clemens Schrimpe interviewt.
Und Clemens Schrimpe ist so der Typ,
für den ich hauptsächlich
eine Zeit lang Freakshow gehört habe.
Der Typ ist der,
der übelst Ahnung von
Netzwerkzeug hat
und von ganz viel über die Telekom rantet.
Ist auch sehr empfehlenswert,
ihm auf Twitter zu folgen und
Telekom hilft, auf Twitter zu folgen.
Und dann siehst du manchmal so hin und
her zwischen ihm und Telekom
hilft, wie er dann auch wie
Werbeaktionen kritisiert
und das ist immer herrlich zu lesen.
Und der hat auch super viel Ahnung
und es haben
sich schon länger Leute gewünscht, dass der
seinen eigenen Podcast kriegt. Und der hat irgendwie
fünf Folgen am Anfang von diesem Podcast
alleine gefüllt. Und das sind irgendwie so drei Stunden
Folgen über IT und Sachen.
Und das Letzte, was ich mir angehört habe,
was neulich erst rauskam,
als ich es wieder angefangen habe zu hören, ist
ein Podcast über Aski.
Nicht über uns, über das Café?
Doch. Nein.
Über Aski und das war nicht mit
Clemens Schrümpel, sondern ich glaube,
das ist die Folge hier,
genau, mit Michael Steil.
Und der erzählt
die Geschichte von Aski von vorne
nach hinten. Zum einen ist
derjenige, der den Namen
der Aski
mit standardisiert hat oder der im Standard
drinsteht, ist
VintSurf.
Das ist ein total geiler Name.
Das ist ein total geiler Name. Ich will auch VintSurf.
Er hat im Prinzip die Geschichte von den ersten
von Morsecode bis ASCII in diesem Podcast
erzählt. Das ist super spannend.
Er geht dann auch darauf ein, wie
Steuerzeichen verwendet werden.
Da ist man bewusst geworden, du
STRG D und STRG L
und STRG W in deiner
Konsole tippst, um damit Sachen zu machen,
dass du eigentlich damit ASCII-Zeichen eingibst.
Klar, die werden das auch nicht gewendet,
beziehungsweise haben halt eine andere Funktion.
Ja, wenn du Steuerung, ich muss mal hier ASCII-Table aufmachen.
Also du nimmst dir quasi das Zeichen, was du tippst.
Das ist hier das L, das ist Code Nummer 76.
Davon ziehst du 64 ab.
Dann bist du bei 12 und 12 ist H.
Und damit löscht du dein gesamtes Terminal.
und Steuerung
W ist 87,
entspricht also der
23,
rechne ich gerade richtig,
und das ist End of Transmission,
damit löschst du dann deine Zeile rückwärts.
Oh, nice. Super nice.
Oder Steuerung
D, D ist
68, minus 64
ist 4, das ist End of Transmission,
damit machst du dein Terminal zu.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Und am schönsten ist
STRG, das ist 71,
also
15,
nee, äh, äh, warte,
71 minus ist 5.
Rechne ich gerade richtig?
Nee, 7.
Ist die Bell.
Das heißt, wenn du das tippst,
dann geht es bei dir
Visual Bell an.
Und das liegt daran, dass du dieses Aske-Zeichen
tippst. Ja, das war mir bewusst,
aber ich wusste nicht, dass STRG die Bell natürlich
tippt.
Das geht halt glaube ich nur bei den Buchstaben, aber das war mir halt nicht wirklich bewusst.
Und das ist dementsprechend ein sehr empfehlenswerter Podcast.
Sehr, sehr cool.
Was ist denn noch so an Debake, was passiert in der letzten Folge?
Also eine Sache, die jetzt noch relativ aktuell ist, ist diese ganze Sache um diese Software namens PCWahl10,
das vom CCC gepublished wurde.
Das ist diese tolle Software, die mittlerweile seit Jahrzehnten, glaube ich, genutzt wird,
um Wahlergebnisse zu sammeln bei uns hierzulande.
Wir kriegen diese Folge vor der Bundestagswahl veröffentlicht?
Ich will es versuchen auf jeden Fall.
Sehr gut.
Die ist ja jetzt noch exakt eine Woche hin, die Bundestagswahl.
Das schaffen wir.
Also ihr wisst jetzt
rückrechnet, wann wir diese Folge wieder aufnehmen.
Ja, PCWahl10
ist anscheinend keine sehr tolle Software.
Die wird genutzt.
Also nachdem ich den
Logbuch-Netz-Politik dazugehört habe,
den ich auch sehr empfehlen kann, habe ich mir gedacht,
ich habe glaube ich als 15-Jähriger
mehr Gedanken über Sicherheit als die Leute, die diese
Software geschrieben haben. Die wird halt benutzt,
um Wahlergebnisse zu sammeln,
zu publizieren
und alles mögliche zu versenden, was auch immer du
damit machst, wenn du die lokal
ausgezählt hast. Also wir haben ja
hier so lange, Gott sei Dank, ich glaube, keine
Wahlautomaten.
Aber irgendwo müssen diese ausgezählten
Tapiere, die werden natürlich nicht irgendwo eingeschickt.
Genau, die Händisch gezählt und dann wird diese Software genutzt,
um das von den lokalen
Wahlstellen
dann irgendwie zentral zu sammeln.
Und das Problem ist, dass das quasi eigentlich bloß Frontend für FDP ist oder sowas.
Mehr oder weniger.
Das laden alle auf den gleichen Server hoch und die haben auch alle das gleiche Passwort.
Das wird einfach alles als Datei irgendwo dahin gelegt.
Und im Endeffekt kann jeder Wahlkreis von jedem anderen Wahlkreis die ganze Zeit auf die Daten zugreifen und das manipulieren.
Vor allem die halt das Schreiben verändern.
Und das ist auch irgendwie bloß gehostet gewesen irgendwo bei 1&1 oder Hetzner auf so einem Shared-House,
wo noch 5.000 andere Leute mit drauf sind.
und auf der gleichen Kiste war
die Software selbst, die man sich runterladen sollte
und jetzt, wo
der Chaos Computer Club natürlich da auf
irgendwelche Schwachstellen gewiesen hat, haben sie gesagt,
ja, okay, wir patchen das, ladet euch
jetzt mal alle von dem Server die Software
neu runter, sodass ihr auch denkt,
nein, ladet euch jetzt nicht die Software runter.
Vor allem ist der Update-Prozess der Software
auch wunderbar, du kannst ja wirklich
überall das Zeug bekommen, kommentieren.
Die Installer sind nicht signiert,
die Daten werden verschlüsselt
mit einem handgezwirbelten
Verfahren, was der
in Lockbox-Nest-Politik
mitinterviewt wird,
gemeint hat, in einer drastischen Zugfahrt
mal eben gecrackt zu haben.
Und es wird halt
verschlüsselt,
aber nicht authentifiziert,
also nicht signiert.
Du kannst zwar nicht reingucken
in diese öffentlichen Wahlergebnisse,
die eh veröffentlicht werden,
aber du kannst auch nicht sicherstellen,
dass die nicht manipuliert wurden.
Voll. Das ist total
nutzlos. Wirklich hane Büchen. Da fragst du dich
manchmal, das ist eigentlich krass, was für Leute
von so einer
Arbeit ihren Lebensunterhalt
bezahlen können. Eigentlich
hätten da Leute
gefeuert werden müssen. Aber das machen
wir einfach schon seit Jahren so.
Das haben wir schon gemacht. Wenn du theoretisch
darüber nachdenkst, das ist jetzt rausgekommen.
Das ist schon seit
Anfang an sicherlich.
Ja, du kannst im Prinzip jetzt
zurückgehen und fast alle
Bundestagswahrergebnisse anfechten.
Wahrscheinlich jede Wahl, wo das benutzt wird.
Ist schrecklich. Super gruselig.
Also genauere Details hört euch Logbuch
Netzpolitik Folge
Folge von
vor zwei Folgen an.
Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass es
jetzt nicht genutzt wird für die kommende
Bundestagswahl. Jetzt gerade wo
jeder weiß, dass das Zeug absolut
vulnerable ist.
Auf jeder Ebene.
so lange her die Folge
ein Standort auf Sand gebaut
nee das ist die letzte
und dann müsste es die davor sein
interessierte Bürger
also LNP 228
absolut gruselig
irgendjemand hat da auf Twitter gepostet
die AfD-Wähler beschweren sich jetzt schon
und beklagen den Verlust von 120%
ihrer Stimmen
Okay. Schön finde ich auch,
dass die ganzen Tools, die mal
kurz geschrieben wurden, um diese Software anzugreifen,
stehen alle aufgetablichen.
Walrus
PC war halt
sein Hacking Tools. Walrus
vor allem.
Ah, hier. Drei Tools, äh, drei
Programme sind das. Das erste ist
zum Updates decrypten.
Das zweite ist, um die
Secret Passwords
zu recoveren.
Und das dritte kannst du benutzen, um
die Votes von einer Party und der anderen
mitzutauschen.
Wunderbar.
Also der Patch, die Wahlresultate.
Schrecklich, dass es anscheinend so easy
einfach ist.
Ja, super gruselig.
Und dann gab es irgendwie noch einen neuen Bleed.
Also
und zwar hat jemand
veröffentlicht
rtpbleed.com
Das habe ich einfach bloß mal auf Twitter gesehen.
und das dann weitergeleitet
an jemanden, der RTP
tatsächlich benutzt.
Und der hat gemeint, der schuldigt mir jetzt ein Bier.
Das ist wieder so eine wunderschöne Webseite,
ein wunderschönen Logo, wo 1 zu 1 dokumentiert
ist, was ist das Problem, wie kann man es ausnutzen,
wer ist wahrscheinlich betroffen.
Genau, und da kann man quasi
This weakness allows malicious users
to inject and receive RTP-Streams
of ongoing calls without needing
be positioned as a man in the middle.
Okay.
Ja,
rtpbleed.com
Mit einem schönen Logo von so einem Punker,
der in ein blutendes Telefon reinschreit.
Genau. Ein Thema, was
wir vorhin irgendwie halb angefangen, aber nur
dann doch abgebrochen haben, als wir über
Soundcloud
und iTunes geredet haben, ist mir
eingefallen, wie werden eigentlich so Podcast
Feeds verteilt?
Ich weiß, ich finde
Feed ohne weiteres in meiner
Podcast-App.
Und wir sind eingetragen bei Feed, also bei
FIT und bei
iTunes, aber
wer
schaut denn jetzt nur bei wem nach,
wo schon was Neues da ist. Also ich
weiß, dass wir
diesen Bug bei iTunes getriggert haben und
deswegen überhaupt nirgendwo
veröffentlicht wurden. Also auf iTunes ist
ein Problem aufgetreten und auf meinem Android-Handy
habe ich die neue Version, die neue Folge
auch nicht gesehen. Ja, hättest du den Feed
Apple verteilt. Apple republished ja
quasi nur unseren Feed. Das heißt,
die ganzen Android-Anwendungen werden wahrscheinlich
einfach auch alle bei iTunes nachschauen.
Apple hat halt das größte Podcast-Verzeichnis.
Und das Schöne ist, dass Apple sich da auch nicht
wirklich dazwischen schaltet, sondern
die leiten das Blätter.
Und anscheinend haben
sie bloß, wenn sie selber diesen
Parsing-Ager reinholen, dann
ist auch die Weiterleitung anscheinend futsch.
Was sehr komisch ist.
Aber zumindest hast du so die
Möglichkeit,
Nutzer von Apple Podcasts, also die Leute,
die Podcasts direkt in iTunes reinziehen
oder auf dem Handy über die Apple eigene App runterladen,
die kriegen das direkt aus dem Store.
Aber die Downloads laufen trotzdem alle über den Originalserver.
Da schiebt sich Apple nirgendwo dazwischen.
Können wir eigentlich direkt über iTunes hosten?
Nee, Apple hostet das eben nicht.
Apple hostet keine Podcasts.
Die sind bloß ein Index.
Das finde ich sehr angenehm.
Da schaltet sich Apple nicht dazwischen.
Wollen wir dann mal zu unserem beliebten Bereich
GitHub-Stars der Woche, die wir jetzt einmal umbenennen
auf generelle Pics,
die nicht mehr nur GitHub-Stars sein müssen, umschwenken.
Also ich finde, das ist alles
GitHub-Stars hier. Vieles, aber
ich habe auch die gefunden, die nicht mehr
reine GitHub-Repos sind, die ich
damit reinziehen würde.
Dann müssen wir für die halt Repos anlegen, wenn die es da ist.
Toll.
Na, gehen wir mal durch. Was hast du denn?
Also ich würde anfangen mit
Pretty Algorithms. Okay.
Du hast so eine Zusammentragung von Algorithmen
in JavaScript implementiert.
die hübsch anzuschauen sind.
Schön mit
Tests dazu
und die Ausgabe von den
Tests und Algorithmen ist durchaus
sehr sehenswert und es ist auch schön, sich
bestimmte Codes mal
in einer, ja was gibt es ja eine relativ
lesbare Sprache,
um angucken zu können, da sind hier unterschiedliche
Sorting-Algorithmen drin und
Such-Algorithmen, aber auch sowas wie
Huffman-Coding
und
Coins-Change-Making
weiß nicht, was das genau ist.
Das fand ich aber eigentlich wieder mal so ein
liebevolles GitHub-Repo,
was mir besonders
unabhängig davon positiv aufgefallen ist,
ist dieses Testing-Frame, was wir hier verwenden,
um das zu visualisieren.
Und das ist Jest.
Und das ist auch super hübsch.
Können wir fast mit, das geht abends da erwähnen.
Wenn man JavaScript gerade macht, Jest ist toll.
Ja, Jest ist super schick.
Das macht
eine schöne Ausgabe. Vielleicht benutze ich das mal
für das, was ich jetzt gerade mache,
anstatt Mokka.
Ich müsste meine ganzen Tests fast, aber es beschreibt sich fast
genauso wie Mokka, ehrlich gesagt.
Cool. Das ist nicht weit weg davon. Genau, das
war mein erster. Jetzt du.
Ich habe als Spaß
dieses Mal ein tolles Projekt
und anscheinend schon fünf Jahre alt,
das ist ein JavaScript-Ypo,
heißt Fuckit.js
und das ist ein wunderbares,
kleines Tool, was dein Code
nimmt, schaut, ob irgendwo Fehler
auftreten und wenn Fehler auf irgendeine Art
und wenn sie auftreten, dann wird diese Zeile einfach gelöscht.
Und dann ruft er sich selbst rekursiv auf
und
nennt das Ganze ein
Eval, Rinse, Reload and Repeat Loop.
Jetzt verlöscht er einfach
den gesamten Code, weil je mehr Zeilen du löscht,
desto mehr neue Fehler fügst du.
Das ist doch wunderbar. Am Ende kommt da nichts mehr raus.
Und hier steht es wunderschön dabei,
wenn du Faket aufrufst,
this will keep evaluating your code
until all arrows have been sliced off like
a piece of perfectly good bread.
Whether or not the remaining code is even worth executing,
we don't know.
we regularly care.
Und dann gibt es noch zwei Methoden,
fuck it, no conflict,
falls du mehrere Fuck-it-Libraries benutzt,
hilft aber sowieso
nicht, weil die sich alle gegenseitig überschreiben,
aber wenigstens kannst du dich
so fühlen, als ob du irgendwas cooles tust.
Und dann gibt es noch, es liegen so,
dass du fuck it, no conflict noch fuck it, more conflict.
More conflict.
Und das
overwritet einfach jede einzelne Property
auf dem globalen Window-Objekt.
Und auch wenn es einen Browser
killt, scheißegal, das
wirkt halt mehr Konflikt
erzeugen, finde ich
wunderbar schön.
Die FAQ, is this a good idea? Of course
not. Is it evil?
See question number one.
Ja,
Spaßprojekt, ich find's toll.
Ist witzig. Hattest du nicht auch
WTFJS aufgezählt?
What the fuck
JavaScript? Ja, wenn nicht, dann mach ich
das einfach mal. Es gibt WTFJS
oder what the fuck JavaScript
a list of funny and tricky JavaScript
Examples und das ist quasi
das ist sowas wie awesome JavaScript
das geht hier runter
ohne Ende weiter
es ist
das ist so eine
pure readme MD
Gitrebo Geschichte
und tonnenweise Beispiele wo du dir denkst
und das ist aber auch wunderschön erklärt
wie er hier Sachen macht, also ich suche gerade mal dieses eine
Beispiel, genau, du hast hier
it's a fail
you would not believe it, but
und dann hat er diesen Code hier, was irgendwie eine komplette
Zeile ist, die eigentlich
nur aus runden und eckigen Klammern
mit Plus und Ausrufezeichen besteht.
Das heißt wirklich runden Klammer auf, Ausrufezeichen,
Klammer auf, Klammer zu, Plus.
Das liest sich überhaupt nicht. Das sieht so aus wie BrainFuck.
Aber wenn du das nimmst und in
Node mal pastest,
dann evaluiert das zu dem String
Fail. Was?
Und
das geht ja hier, dass die Explanation ist
wunderschön. Du liest dir das ja durch.
und dann schaust du dir halt an, was der macht.
Das ist der erste Teil davon.
Ich gebe euch mal ganz kurz darauf ein.
Der erste ist in runden Klammern.
Ausrufezeichen, geschweifte Klammern.
Also leeres Array plus leeres Array.
Das ist False.
Und dann gehen wir halt darauf ein,
wie er irgendwie mit dem Plus-Apperator forciert,
dass das zu einem String gepasst wird.
Dann spielt er weiter mit den Ohren rum,
um daraus nur das FA zu nehmen.
Hier.
F kommt dann raus.
Irgendwie bei dem I wurde es tricky.
Also die
Buchstaben aussehen. Also F-A-I kriegst du ja alle
aus F-A-R-S raus.
Das ist super geil.
Was zum Teufel.
Ja und dann hat er irgendwie hier
ein ParseInt und da kommt dann
auf den String Infinity.
Und der parst aber immer bloß
Infinity und
also ParseInt gibt
dir an, was die Basis ist.
Das heißt, du kannst irgendwie was nach
als Hexzahl oder als Binary-Zahl,
da geht man ja durch.
Bei ParseIn 10
kommt Not a Number raus, 18 ist auch Not a Number,
19 kommt 18 raus,
bei 23 kommt
18 raus, bei 24 kommt
eine achtstellige Zahl raus,
die Zahlen werden immer größer, bei 37 ist es wieder
None.
Also WTF.js.
Sehr schön, lesbar.
Das wäre alles, was
für diesen wunderschönen Wack-Talk
von Gary Bernhardt, heißt er, glaube ich.
Genau, der ist ja, glaube ich, auch als YouTube-Video einfach verlinkt.
Schön.
Das zeigen wir immer Informatik-Studenten
in den Erstsemestern, aber ich glaube, die meisten verstehen
natürlich zu dem Zeitpunkt, wie witzig das ist.
Aber es ist schon toll.
Du solltest in den Informatik-Erstsemestern
glaube ich erstmal was über Code-Formatierung erzählen.
Ja, ne, witzige.
Ach nee, das waren die Maschinenbau-Erstsemester.
Nee, das waren drei Semestern.
Das spielt keine Rolle.
So, weiter.
Ich habe noch ein tolles Ding gerade heute
auf Hacker News gefunden, das heißt
Schrödinger TCL
oder Schrödingerst TCL.
TCL, wie ich vorhin erst rausgefunden habe,
ist ja anscheinend irgendeine C-Library.
Ich dachte, das wäre eigentlich eine eigene Sprache, aber es spielt gar nicht
mehr so die Rolle, denn
warum es sich so ist, dass
er eine kleine Library hat,
die einen Wert verändert, sobald man Lust gibt.
Aber nur in dem Fall.
Und wenn du ihn einfach weiterverwendest, dann hat er halt
den originalen Wert. Also es heißt
Bergschutz-Unschärferelation, wenn du
hinguckst. Genau, ich hätte eigentlich nichts
zu tun. Doch, passt schon.
Natürlich
total bescheuertig, aber das ist einfach nur witzig.
Auch gar keine Ahnung, ich weiß auch nicht, ich verstehe
nicht ganz, wie das hier implementiert ist. Ist zwar nur C,
aber what?
Und ich wüsste auch spaßenshalber nicht,
wie ich das in anderen Sprachen
implementieren würde.
Das wäre mal eine interessante Übung, falls es
überhaupt möglich ist, dass wenn man
Dinge ausgibt, sie sich verändert.
Also wenn du sie natürlich mit Bordmitteln ausgibst,
nicht irgendwie...
Eigentlich kacke.
Das willst du gerade nicht.
Natürlich willst du es nicht.
Das ist halt der Inbegriff von Seiteneffekten.
Aber es ist spannend, wie man das...
Ich musste mich gerade mal selber weiterbilden
und bin jetzt auf der Webseite von TCL.
Die haben erstmal
eine sehr schöne Visualisierung von ihrem
Gip Source Code auf der Startseite.
Warum sind die auf tcl.tk?
Das ist ein super Top-Level-Domain.
Naja, das ist
core.tcl.tk.
Ach, weil das TCLTK heißt auch die Organisation?
Ja, das ist halt das Toolkit.
Ach so, jetzt habe ich verstanden.
TCLTK.
Das ist irgendwie was,
ja, das gibt es auch schiebig, glaube ich,
und war vorher auf SourceForge gehostet.
SourceForge ist ja mittlerweile
nicht mehr sketchy, habe ich gelernt letztens.
Ach so? Die wurden ja wiederverkauft
und der neue
Inhaber will es wieder
bleiben. Also SourceForge ist in dem
Moment gestorben, als ich da irgendwie Installer
für Open-Source-Tools runtergeladen habe,
die gleichzeitig noch irgendwelche Werbungen
mit installiert haben.
Aber hier gehen auch schon wieder irgendwelche Pop-Ups auf,
wenn ich mir die Seite aufmache.
Das sieht nicht viel anders aus, als das letzte Mal, als ich geguckt habe.
Ja, nee, anders sieht es nicht aus.
Aber die wollen den Scheiß wieder rauskriegen.
Die haben ja echt richtig sketchy Kram zu hinterher.
Das ist dann heutzutage noch der Use Case von sowas wie Source-Watch.
Die waren ja quasi der Ursprung für das,
was heute GitHub macht.
Die hosten ja auch deine Projektseite, nicht nur statischen Content.
Ja, du hast halt alles
zur Projektentwicklung.
ein Forum noch daneben legen oder so.
Das ist schon ganz nett.
Also GitHub war
so die Offenbarung, als es rauskam,
weil es halt nicht so fürchterlich
unübersichtlich war wie SourceForge immer.
Dass du da irgendwie was gefunden hast, was dich interessiert hat.
Das stimmt schon.
So, was haben wir denn
noch? Wir haben noch ein paar Stars.
Genau, also wir haben ja mal über
Package Manager gesprochen und
ein Bekannter hat mir noch
Spack
empfohlen.
ein flexibler Package Manager, der
verschiedene Versionen unterstützt, Konfigurierung,
Plattform und Compiler. Das ist quasi wieder so ein
Metapacket Manager.
Da schreibst du deine Format-Dateien,
deine Manifest-Dateien schreibst du in Python.
Der ist auch, glaube ich,
vollständig in Python geschrieben. Der wird aber ganz intensiv
von der
High-Performance-Computing
Community benutzt. Das ist einfach
für C++.
Der baut halt alles komplett vom Source.
Und der Typ, den mir
davon erzählt hat,
sehr davon geschwärmt.
Okay.
Wir müssen generell mal mehr über Package Manager
erlauben.
Haben wir schon den Package Manager Podcast,
den es...
Haben wir noch nicht empfohlen?
Also es gibt irgendwie...
Haben die schon neuere Folgen?
Zwei Folgen haben sie aktuell.
Das war einmal CocoaPods und einmal Homebrew.
Genau, also so richtig spannend wurde es für mich noch nicht.
Ich würde gerne mal so Sachen Bundler
und Cargo und
NPM und Nix.
Und dann sowieso die ganzen
Linux
Paketmanager wie Pac-Man
und
Debian Packaging und
The Manifest heißt ja übrigens
der Podcast.
Kommt in die Shownotes.
Dann habe ich noch ein Projekt, das wollte ich gerade mal an
Zadina-Satellite nicht gebaut. Das habe ich
hier bloß reingeschrieben, weil es so einen total försterlichen
Namen hat.
Das heißt
Cancer.
Also so wie
Krebs.
Genau, und das heißt
Cancer, weil es Terminal
ist.
Da hab ich mir gedacht,
das ist ein Terminal Emulator.
Und da steht einfach, in der ersten
Zeile von der Readmeave auf GitHub steht
It's Terminal.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, du hast gerade den Preis
für geschmacklosesten
Projektdaten gewonnen.
Das war großartig.
Das hat bei mir nicht gebaut und ich wollte
in meinem Lab nicht in das Mikrofon
von unserem Aufnahmengerät reinpusten lassen.
Dann nehme ich mal meinen letzten Pick noch mit rein.
Das ist jetzt nicht mal kein GitHub Repub,
sondern eigentlich tatsächlich ein YouTube-Video.
Und man das wahrscheinlich auch gut als Anleitung
in einem GitHub Repub posten könnte.
Als Anleitung ist es aber ziemlich ausführlich.
Das ist ein Typ, der hat 16 Wochen Arbeit reingesteckt.
Ich glaube, es war ein 16.
Das ist ein 20-minütiges Video.
Das lohnt sich mal, wenn ihr ein bisschen Interesse an Elektronik habt.
Und der hat ein iPhone 7 gekauft.
Und er fand es doof, dass das keinen Klinkenstecker mehr hat.
Ist auch scheiße.
Hashtag Courage.
Und er hat alles herangesteckt, um rauszufinden, ob es möglich ist, einen reinzubauen in sein iPhone selbstständig.
Und er lebt in Shenzhen in China, die Hauptstadt für jegliche Form von Elektronik.
Oder alles, was damit zu tun hat.
Und hat sich ein bisschen umgehört, ein bisschen umgeschaut und angefangen hat zu basteln.
Und ist letztendlich darauf gekommen, dass er,
also wenn ihr das Video anschauen wollt,
dann schaut es lieber jetzt gleich an, bevor ihr weiterhört.
So ein Spoiler, wie es ausgeht.
Und hat den Adapter, den es von Apple gibt,
der von Lightning auf Klingenstecker geht,
für Legacy-Kopfhörer, sage ich einfach mal,
hat den auseinandergenommen, reverse-ingeniert,
den quasi in den neuen Chip gegossen,
nachdem er herausgefunden hat, das funktioniert,
diesen Chip flexibel gedruckt und unten reingebaut in sein iPhone.
Und hat sich dann noch mit dem
C-Fäse von einem Freund
ein richtig sauberes Loch unten
reinschen, wo er dann diesen Stecker verbaut hat, wo tatsächlich
ein klein bisschen Platz drin ist.
Der Platz war noch da dafür.
Gerade so.
Ich glaube, der
Hauptgrund, warum sie das abgeschafft haben,
ist, damit sie mehr Platz im Gehäuse
für anderes Zeugs haben. Das kommt später.
Die haben den abgeschafft und nicht im selben
Jahr ausgefüllt, damit sie den Stress
erstmal los haben und später dann
darüber gerettet wird.
Das ist jetzt durch.
Er macht ein Startup auf und bietet Klickenstecker nachrüsten
as a Service an.
Das finde ich ganz cool am Ende.
Er hat das Design von dem Chip und alles komplett offen gestellt,
frei zum Download.
Ich vermute mal, es gibt irgendeine kleine Firma in China,
aus Shenzhen, die jetzt diese Dinge baut
und dein iPhone für einen gewissen Preis komplett umgustet.
Aber es funktioniert halt tadellos.
Er hat am Ende quasi ein iPhone,
wo dieser Adapter von der Logik her komplett eingebaut ist.
Du kannst deswegen leider nicht beide Ports gleichzeitig benutzen.
Aber das Hot Swapping funktioniert tadellos.
von den System super erkannt. Es ist beeindruckend,
was für einen Haufen Arbeit.
Die meisten solchen Sachen sind ja
heutzutage in Geräten eh schon über
USB oder über irgendeinem anderen Standard-Dings
angeschlossen. Das sind ja dann innerhalb von
einem Gerät trotzdem unabhängige Geräte.
Also ob du da nur so einen Adapter ransteckst
oder ob du das im Gehäuse hast, macht
von der Hardware, glaube ich, bereits beim vorherigen
iPhone keinen Unterschied. Du musst ja
trotzdem irgendwo festlöten und
die Logik dann damit reingehst.
Also das ist trotzdem beeindruckend.
Ich verstehe, was du meinst, aber schau es mir mal an, das Video. Das ist unglaublich cool.
und der Typ ist auch unglaublich sympathisch, das ist der selbe Typ,
der hat schon mal ein Video hochgeladen, wo er
ausschließlich aus Ersatzteilen,
die er auf irgendeiner Ersatzteil-Märkte in Shenzhen
gefunden hat, ein eigenes
iPhone gebaut hat, komplett aus
Ersatzteilen.
Der ist also wirklich sehr...
Und er hat halt auch, er sagt glaube ich auch nochmal, er ist nicht
jemand mit irgendwelchen riesigen Backgrounds in Electronics,
sondern er ist Softwareentwickler und
versucht einfach mal da
durch Trial and Error
irgendwo hinzukommen und das funktioniert halt wunderbar.
Ich meine, er hat den besten geografischen
einen Ort dafür gefunden,
das zu machen. An dem Ort, wo alles
eh herkommt und hergestellt wird.
Und zusammenläuft.
Ist unglaublich cool. Wo du jetzt gerade auf YouTube
empfohlen hast, würde ich noch eine
Sache reinigen. Es gibt irgendwie von
vox.com
eine schöne Unterreihe. Das hat jetzt gar nichts damit
zu tun, aber die heißt Irr.
Das ist über
Musik. Ich habe ja das letzte Mal, glaube ich,
schon über den Podcast, den ich
neu gefunden habe,
Switched on Pop erzählt.
Und Vox ist so ein...
Die haben erst vier Videos raus,
aber die haben ein Video komplett,
zehn Minuten lang, über ein bestimmtes...
Über einen Radiohead-Song
und warum die Rhythmik da drin so faszinierend ist
oder warum bestimmte...
Warum diese Mariah Carey
Weihnachtsabung so weihnachtlich klingt.
Was ist das, was daran weihnachtlich klingt?
Das ist halt auf eine bestimmte Harmonie,
die in vielen jazzigen Weihnachtsliedern
blöden wird, zurückzuführen.
Und warum es schöner ist,
wenn Popsongs ausfaden,
als wenn sie aufhören.
Und das ist eigentlich wunderschön erzählt.
Deswegen würde ich das jetzt auch gerne mal kurz
pluggen. Verlink es mal in die Journalistik.
Genau, das mache ich. Cool.
So.
Damit wären wir, glaube ich, auch größtenteils
wieder am Ende von der Folge.
Hoffen wir, dass die nächste nicht wieder so lange dauert,
wie diese jetzt gerade.
Du meinst, bis zur nächsten Folge.
Ja.
Also wir werden definitiv bei der nächsten Folge wissen,
wer der neue Bundeskanzler wird.
Oder bleibt.
davon gehe ich fest aus, weil sonst
müssten wir die sehr bald aufnehmen
Ja, wir können uns ja
übermorgen nochmal treffen, bestimmt bis dahin wieder ein paar Sachen
Dann wird die alt nicht mal gepublished und dann
Also vielen Dank, das war
Akronomie-Serverfolge 9
Wir waren
Kilian
und Hendrik, ihr findet uns
auf Twitter unter unseren Handels
wie bekannt, ich bin
huli-de
Ich bin Kilian, K-O-E mit 1 L
Oder add akronomisierbar.
Feedback bitte, Korrekturen
und was hört ihr für,
was benutzt ihr für Schriftarten?
Alles.
Was sind eure Lieblings-Color-Schemes?
Uh, auch interessant.
Auch interessant.
Schreibt uns das bitte über Twitter
und hiermit verabschieden wir uns.
Und die nächste Folge,
der nächste Podcast in eurem Feed
kommt in 2, 1, 2.